l'émission qui fait
émission qui fait
l'émission des bourgeois
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
chers amis chers ennemis
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle émission qui fait
avec nous ce soir
[Musique]
damas
est ce que bell
échanger
ben laden
jack à
stanley ho
ian gillan de people
[Applaudissements]
réglable et laurent baffie
oh
[Musique]
tu aimes ton public et au 8e rang bien
alors j'ai pas envie de bosser surtout
je préfère être là avec nous j'ai pas
envie de dire de devon j'ai pas envie de
peindre j'ai pas envie de voir les gens
ouais j'ai eu un coup de barre - étaient
attaqués à préparer là parce que c'est
que les gens pour faire un petit truc ça
en fin de saison tout un
don c'est relâche un peu ta rien du tout
là j'ai trois coups de peinture un
talkie walkie des cartes de bons clients
toujours pareil cas et voilà un était à
tapas préparées la vanne qui tue la non
je m'en branle un peu
que tu veux qu'on fasse non mais si tu
as envie de rien très franchement moi
j'ai envie de rien si on pouvait arrêter
maintenant les toucher mais je dis à moi
c'est comme tu veux si tu veux penser
non mais vraiment dit ce soir non
personne laisse tomber on arrête alors
tu peux pas la faire on a fait pas alors
on l'a fait ou pas
merci ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voulais partir juste en sortant je
croisais le directeur de projet il m'a
dit je te la paye pas celle là
[Musique]
quand
m
et maintenant
ainsi josiane balasko
[Musique]
bonsoir josiane
vous êtes bien acheté avez-vous parce
que ça dure
je ne me pose pas de questions dès le
départ mais c'est quoi c'est tout c'est
de la ceinture et cécile de france ya
longtemps
josiane je vais vous dire la vérité
c'est que ce décor donc les verts comme
vous le voyez il est évolutif
28 mai et toitures en europe 1 les repas
inclus semaine dernière on avait des
tagueurs qui nous ont bien aidés
d'ailleurs que je remercie mes sens bien
et qu'elle
que je salue ici qu'ils reviendront
sûrement voilà encore un repas on essaye
d'arranger des trucs mais bon ça sans
rien arriver à faire les choses tout
seul ça part en couille la vérité ces
charges qualité mais on était d'accord
ça fait pas mention ses décors ils
marchent pas quoi voilà c'est tout bon
voilà bon allez l'organe yale herrero
bonsoir mais non non merde alors
l'avantagé avec vous je dis aime balasko
c'est qu'on vous présente plus ce qui
pour un animateur télé est super facile
josiane balasko qu'on ne présente plus
voilà la machette mais quand on voit
arriver comme ça veut dire pour un bon
animateur télé c'est un peu
déstabilisant parce que vous avez un
aplomb extraordinaire j'ai dû apprendre
ça dans le bistrot ouais ouais mec
bourré ouais pas s'éloigner des
animateurs
la raison
l'enregistreur de ses parents bien alors
on vous présente plus comme j'ai dit
pour résumer on pourrait dire josiane
balasko que vous avez un césar d'honneur
sans avoir eu besoin d'être mourante me
suis posé des questions d'ailleurs à ce
qu'est ce qu'ils vont vous donner qu'on
voudrait le cancer mais écouter des
médicaments des médicaments
tu vois le cancer c'est pas sur un
alzheimer on attend une chance tous cas
bien alors ils en rigolent plus là vous
êtes ici pour un film dans lequel vous
faites une performance qui est césar is
able vous souvenez ce que je vous dis
parce que chaque année je prédis les
césars aux gens et je me trompe rarement
c'est vrai laurent c'est vrai thierry
c'est jean le bon compagnon tu vois j'ai
dit alors c'est un film de guillaume
nicloux dont j'avais déjà vu une affaire
privée avec thierry lhermitte et c'est
d'ailleurs thierry lhermitte qui vous a
présenté ce guillaume nicloux un oui m'a
appelé en me disant on reçoit le c'est
un mec formidable je viens de tourner
avec lui vas-y en confiance ouais il un
ton le mec un secteur dans ce final
s'appelle cette somme là donc il y avoue
d'ailleurs pour ça que vous êtes là il
ya eric caravaca aurélien recoing
thierry lhermitte et ça sort le 15
octobre voilà alors je vais faire le
pitch mais je fasse le pitre en asie le
pitch est très simple c'est le portrait
intérieur d'une femme flic à travers une
enquête
mais sauf que cette femme là est assez
perturbé quand le film démarre elle est
en fait très proche de la dépression
parce que c'est une femme qui a perdu
son enfant dans des circonstances
tragiques un accident dont elle se sent
responsable et cet enfant est mort un 29
février une année bissextile et tous les
quatre ans elle est vraiment roi des
démons elle est en proie à des
cauchemars elle pense à la mort et et l'
enquête qu'elle va mener va la conduire
vraiment la rapprocher de ses démons et
les faire passer des épreuves terribles
faire qu'elles enquêtent sur un sur un
suicide on pensait pas vraiment
d'ailleurs et cette histoire se mêle à
ses cauchemars personnel et le talent de
guillaume c'est d'avoir réussi à
les jetons aux sanglots tateurs quand on
voit le film alors le personnage est
très introverti très dépressif aux
antipodes de la grande gueule que vous
avez l'habitude de jouer dans les films
est particulièrement calme oui oui j'ai
5 0 il guillaume avait demandé un ton
comme ça une musique très dépouillée
alors au début ça me paraissait un peu
curieux je me demandais où il voulait en
venir comment ce personnage allait
réussir à exister avec ceux avec ses
limites de jeu et finalement on trouve
une grande liberté à faire ça et c'est
même assez confortable alors c'est un
film baigné d'un sentiment de malaise de
violences avait beaucoup plus peur qu'un
film d'horreur mais ya pas vraiment de
il n'y a pas vraiment de choses très
spectaculaire mais l'angoissé la peur
elle n'est de ses propres fans de ses
phobies la phobie d'être enterrés
vivants la phobie d'étouffer
peut-être
tu touches la main et ça fait ça mais on
sait pas ce qu'est la peinture ouais
d'accord
regardez quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
je
cette femme-là de 10 ans
josiane balasko et ne peut indiquer ce
soir
je vais vous dire c'est assez rassurant
qui a encore des films comme ça moi je
trouve c'est un vrai film d'auteur avec
un vrai ton une vraie patte en jeu pas
combien de temps ça va durer m'enfin n'y
en a pas il ya une génération comme ça
de metteur en scène qui raconte des
histoires qui aime les acteurs qui ont
un sens de l'atmosphère c'est vraiment
un film d'atmosphère autant bbc
est ce que tu pourrais pas pas d'un truc
là voilà à quoi ça sert qu'on se
décarcasse est question non moi ça m'a
fait rire je suis passé à côté 12e ce
jugement je suis dans ce guide a en plus
d'ancienneté les cheveux longs oui et ça
vous change ouais ah oui c'est
ça
jeudi m les extensions
j'en connais d'autres
on a collé des faux cheveux quand on a
des cheveux de morte enfin je sais pas
non pas des cheveux qui n'est pas moi à
quel effet ça fait alors pas le matin et
ils se mélangent pas mais chez les
faucheuses avec les vrais à c'est
bizarre mais enfin il paraît qu'il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui se font ça en
permanence et c'est pas très sexy parce
que votre fiancée vous met plus la main
dans les cheveux quoi bein oui tu as
fait la croche c'est comme ça des
grosses lente toi
car le plastique des petits bouts de
colle vous êtes contre ces trucs là vous
êtes contre la chirurgie esthétique vous
avez déclaré moi je me suis fait refaire
le nez ya longtemps et donner oui à vous
et fait refaire le même temps oui jma
pourquoi si je sais le maquilleuse
m'avait dit j'étais tout jeune refuse le
profil
tâche et comment tu fais comment je peux
faire pour être de profils parce qu'au
bout d'un moment tu es touche d'armand
et puis voilà pour sa 4ème bravo à
l'époque tony accepte les profils
non j'ai un profil parfait vous avez dit
un truc c'est qu'à force de se faire
refaire les pommettes les lèvres et où
toutes les bonnes femmes finissent par
ressembler les c'est un peu
vrai si le tir on sait qui on sait on a
expérimenté sur les d'accord
sur les grands brûlés pendant la guerre
de 14 ça a été les premiers enfin les
types y avait des gueules cassées
ensuite oreilles travesti je pense que
là ça a été un matériel interne ans et
des femmes maintenant ces femmes qui
sont les cobayes la chirurgie esthétique
alors parlé tout à l'heure du bistrot
vous dites oui j'ai de l'aplomb parce
que j'ai appris ça au bistrot face aux
mecs bourrés et c'est un bistrot où les
gens et ça on s'en souvient pas à
l'époque n'est pas de cantine dans les
usines et à l'usiné citroën y avait pas
de cantine donc les gens venaient chez
les acheter davantage emporté des plats
cuisinés qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient
qu'est-ce qu'on mettait dans ce cas même
qu'est ce qu'y avait il y avait du boeuf
bourguignon et des pommes de frites et
de salade de pommes de terre faillit
jamais bon truc quoi la détruire
d'accusation n'ont jamais qu'est ce qui
à l'en
rien rien il ya ton copain christophe
lambert qu'avant carré viiip c'est vrai
il est tout seul oui le pauvre bon je
bosse à s'accrocher aux branches à le
chercher bien
bien sa vague list of
tu m'entends toi tu m'entends très bien
la voilà bon je t'envoie laurent tu
seras moins seul d'accord je suis
contraint voilà je serai moins constant
dans 5 minutes n'a alors je suis
toujours content bien alors donc dans ce
bistrot que qu'avait vos parents donc
les ouvriers des usines citroën allait
remplir leurs gamelles et votre mère est
arrêtée là votre mère elle s'appelle
s'appelait faire monter ferment et votre
père il s'appelait ivan balasko vix est
un immigré croate et vous avez dit bart
est vrai que ça fait un peu joueur de
football c'était long c'était assez
compliqué à se retenir et à retenir donc
j'ai raccourci j'ai enlevé le vic
d'ailleurs j'utilise de temps en temps
mon vrai nom frappé les taxis etc alors
madame batna covic voilà comme ça donc
j'ai eu bien fait devant vous êtes
incognito vous appelez palace que les
noms alors à 14 ans votre père meurt
d'un cancer du poumon et votre mère vous
avez avertie elle vous avez dit papa est
malade donc elle vous appelle et m'a dit
elle m'a dit ton père est condamné il va
mourir normalement avant donc je savais
que mon père et je la remercie et encore
maintenant de m'avoir prévenu c'est à
dire j'ai profité
voilà oui pas été une surprise et
l'amour nagé jusqu'à la maison n'a
jamais été quelque chose de tabou c'est
vrai maintenant à la limite on n'emmène
pas les enfants aux entièrement n'a
cette peur est alors que les enfants
peuvent très bien
alors quand votre père meurt vous
découvrez que la demi frères k 20 ou 25
ans deux de plus que vous qui est né
là-bas en croatie avant la migration de
votre père en france et après vous avez
revu régulièrement servi régulièrement
n'a maintenant il est disparu aussi mon
fils a des enfants et ouais vous voyez
toujours et son fils arrêtés certains de
ses petits-enfants mon père aussi une
grande tente sont venus à passer les
vacances à paris ouais alors après après
la mort de votre père votre mère prend
une petite auberge dans l'oise 1 là vous
manquer d'argent là c'est un peu
compliqué là bas c'était un peu plus dur
montfort n'a toujours rien à bouffer
de travailler dans la vente à j'ai
travaillé dans la restauration
laurent
rien dire ayant sympathisé d'eau
[Rires]
mais mais c'est diane de france à côté
de vous christophe on s'est vus je vais
piquer sa place dans l'avion ah oui
d'accord mais je dirais j'ai pas des
matches c'est la fille c'est la soeur du
roi laurence et la soeur du l'héritier
du trône vienne 9 mois aussi la soeur
d'henri de france grosses fortunes ou
pas
grand chose à dire il ya 50 ans il avait
un milliard de l'époque maintenant ils
ont 70 millions voilà peut-être tout le
dos maintenant on attend de voir ce que
tu fais on partage
bon allez laurent je t'attends là j'ai
besoin de toi ne les enchaîne bien
j'enchaîne louis donc en fait finalement
face à ces situations qui peut
compliquer vous êtes blindé par
l'orgueil on pourrait dire ouais vous
verrez j'arriverai quoi bien sûr je vous
aurais à la fin bien sûr ça c'est un bon
moteur c'est à dire toutes façons vous
verrez
pas la dernière mais j'ai pas s'y
attendait
c'est une princesse de france le
fonctionnement de l'antenne mais non
c'est une famille royale
enfin pas trop dit ou pas tu veux la
versa alors on n'a rien fait qui rit qui
a donné demander la non c'est pas bien
tu n'ai aucun respect pour cette vieille
race capétienne l'euro qui me fait peur
les rascasses l'europe et diane il a dit
c'est pas gentil à vous le rôle revient
ici tout de suite d'accord service
d'ordre bien il donc là donc à votre
adolescence vous découvrez la bd et puis
aussi philip k.dick sert toute la soirée
oui mais vers 18 en était toute une
bande qui qui avons découvert moi je
voulais faire d'illustration de
nouvelles de science-fiction et toute
une bande qui adorions la sf et je
continue à l'aimer ça a été un point
commun avec guillaume nicloux grand mère
afin qu'on s'est rencontrés on avait on
se rendait compte qu'on a eu les on
avait les mêmes lectures alors là vous
êtes super forte en dessin seul et même
à penninghen incendiés bref c'est bien
ça et puis voilà mais comme vous êtes
nuls en couleurs un jour vous allez voir
tania balachova quai qui est quand même
la grande prof de théâtre de l'époque
pour faire dans votre idée c'était de
faire des décors de théâtre pour
approcher le théâtre pour savoir ce que
c'était moi je connaissais étudier les
classiques un point c'est tout et je
suis arrivé j'ai débarqué au cours avec
mon carton à dessin et balazs vanille
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce carton
ici on apprend à faire du théâtre donc
vous allez laisser le carton à dessin et
voilà et puis là vous êtes aperçu vous
aviez ce qu'on appelle les funny bonne
c'est dire vous avez un pouvoir comique
quoi comme ça oui oui je peux rien faire
suer sang mais bon là bas j'avais
travaillé le texte mais voilà c'est à la
suite un le splendide tout ça après tout
le monde connaît tout le monde connaît
la suite c'est vrai que c'est de vous
remettre avec la bande du splendid pour
faire un truc il en est question
clavier l'avait annoncé publiquement là
tu es donc tu peux le dire après j'ai eu
des remises qui m'a appelé qui m'a dit
on s'est rencontrés on s'est retrouvé
une première fois on a recommencé à rire
arrière comme des bossus donc ça c'est
très bon signe parce que vraiment notre
moteur c'était le rire josiane quand on
vous parle d'amour vous répondez très
simplement très franchement sans aucune
pudeur
au bar des mots ils bavent il est
philippe beyries histoire d'amour voilà
tout ça maintenant il ya jorge aguilar
comédiens indiens d'amérique et oui
voilà quand on parle de sexe c'est
pareil vous répondez toujours très
franchement sans fausse pudeur vous dit
les choses et à 18 ans dans 68 c'était
l'époque de la révolution sexuelle j'ai
eu ma dose ah ouais on a bien s'est bien
éclatés
c'est oui parce que ça et on ne peut pas
s'en rendre compte de ce qu'il n'y avait
pas de problèmes de maladies sexuelles
transmissibles y avait juste le risque
de faire des enfants donc voilà trouille
c'est quand même moins dangereux d'avoir
un enfant que d'avoir le sida donner la
vie c'est moins dangereux 4 apple a
annoncé sur wii et alors c'est l'âge
d'or quoi c'est ça que vous dites en
gros c'était à la limite ont envoyé
quelqu'un faisait la manière dont s'est
moqué c'était déjà une manière de
communiquer à prendre des connaissances
pratiquement
j'aimerais bien mesdemoiselles que
certaines d'entre vous écoutez grossesse
c'était l'âge d'or à la dialyse et vous
l'avez connurent si je connais aussi
l'événement pas à mais je sais bien
c'était formidable alors à vos
apparitions la télévision sont très
rares josiane balasko si on avait plein
de fois à
questions pour un champion
le demi-finaliste oui vous apparition la
télévision sont très rares josiane
balasko l'îlot chiffres au mollet lors
bons chiffres et les lettres aussi que
le fait nous apparaît sur la détection
vous apparaissez jour du seigneur
elle est partout vous apparaît même
s'ils ont la télévision sont très rares
josiane balasko nous offrons son
apparition au jour des seigneurs
extraordinaire nous allons donc créer
maintenant âme une histoire moments
inoubliables
que les émissions à base d'archivés vont
pouvoir diffuser jusqu'à votre prochain
film on va passer à l'interview zapping
[Musique]
ça
josiane le principe est simple on doit
d'ici la fin de cette interview créer un
moment de télévision très fort qui
passera au zapping la femme de la
situation
est ce que vous pourriez faire semblant
comme ça maintenant là tout de suite
d'être bourrée
pourquoi vous me demandez ça parce que
vous avez des problèmes avant non
à
est-ce que vous pouvez insulter
quelqu'un l'a maintenant est
qui qui vous voulez vous oui on ne
s'est pas méchant non c'est vrai
est ce que c'est vrai que vous avez été
victime josiane balasko deux tours
nantes au sein de l'équipe du splendid
j'aurais voulu je ne voulais pas qu'on
aborde
à ce que parce que vraiment on avait
essayé de terre parce que c'était quand
même jugnot qui est sûr c'est que ça
donc vraiment ça c'est une question qui
me gêne c'est le joker c'est le lot oui
c'est de l'envoyer la gueule si je vous
laisse apprécier vous embête voilà il
n'y a pas de problème alors c'est vrai
que justement lhermitte et juniors ont
couché ensemble pendant trois ans ça
aussi j'aurais vite et c'est ça pour la
femme de l'ermite c'est pénible attente
c'est vrai surtout qu'ils ont eu un
enfant est donc
allé à l'époque la fin de l'ère vite ces
géniaux
est-ce que vous avez déjà trompé votre
mec avec un géo du club med
non non ça passera pas au zapping ça dit
oui non non à l'abri la bomba non non
j'ai pas non mais je cherche sur des
soigneurs sont produits et oui soyez
gentils dit oui 28 le team des sports
voilà tu es toujours le mec des
dictatures parapente on va gagner 20
minutes non c'est vachement compliqué
avec le justifie toi
difficile de faire des grands moments à
la télé nouveau buzz pour arthur là pour
les enfants de la télé alors tiens voilà
j'ai le truc lâm zapping assure elle est
secouée montrer vos ça
ça dépend combien on paye quoi
quelque chose aussi tu peux tu peux le
faire c'est vrai que j'ai fait des films
pornos à l'âge de 14 ans
on a participé toute l'équipe du
splendid ah et aussi ceux du café de la
gare à un film qui a dû sortir d'un jeu
70 ce qui s'appelait si vous n'aimez pas
ça n'en dégoûtez pas les autres qui
ressortit d'ailleurs plus tard quand on
a été un peu connu on avait des
bouteilles nous avait dit il ya mille
balles à ce faire il suffit droit
d'aller assister à des projections de
films pornos et on improvise on est les
spectateurs qui improvise on donc on a
passé une journée à regarder des filles
sans fil et des concombres monstrueux
dans les endroits un peu curieux et
chacun y allait être l'improvisation et
ce film-là est sorti dans l'anonymat et
puis quand on est un peu connus certains
équilibres du splendid romain bouteille
avait tout le monde voilà donc c'est
vrai donc on peut dire on peut dire que
c'est vrai on peut dire oui là on peut
dire oui très bien mais ça n'aide plus
d'acheteurs regarder ou fait des films
pendant 14 ans oui oui voilà voilà alors
ça en est où votre histoire avec un
juppé
ben justement comme l'a fait à temps
d'instruction d'ailleurs je préfère pas
parler avec ses tables en plastique
josiane à mona lisa va être salis
zapping et pouvait me dire thierry
je t'aime et puis vous pouvez rajouter
des trucs après sur la taille de mon
sexe et tout mais ça ne s'est pas obligé
qu'est ce que vous voulez comme taille
trentaine de centimes rennes ça serait
sympa john holmes oui allez-y on vous
écoute dirige ce thème ouais
cette femme-là de guillaume nicloux ça
sort le 15 octobre
je veux là
non
et maintenant aubry
c'est christophe lambert
soit
en inde ils se ressemblent vous n'êtes
plus dans la loge déjà oui c'est
alors davantage avec vous c'est un petit
peu comme josiane balasko christophe
lambert on ne vous présente plus j'avais
la balle attiches
à claude françois c'est pas à jour les
fiches
mais non mais c'est après claude
françois est mort ces centres
villes et mordelles jeu c'est bon tu
vois d'ailleurs c'est vrai tu y as
immortel et vous et vous vieillissez
très très très très lentement je trouve
belle c'est bien je suis content merci
non mais vraiment mais vous aussi non
mais c'est vrai alors physiquement vie
c'est pas beau et toi aussi josiane mais
josiane s'attendait qui
non c'est vrai que physiquement oui
c'est très lentement comme josiane
d'ailleurs et mentalement vous êtes
atteint du syndrome de peter pan c'est à
dire que vous avez gardé une âme
d'enfant quoi au messager toujours eu ça
c'est pas
nouveau mais ce film que j'aime bien
j'adore les enfants et alors quel âge
maintenant
12 18 suivant les moments la chambre des
posters alors si tu me parles je vais te
raconter ma maison alors j'ai une statue
de mickey
et puis j'ai un espèce de grand bonhomme
dans une cage qui est bleu avec la tête
à l'envers
et à cuisiner l'aménager comment un tel
bonheur c'est plutôt moderne nogent lès
lure eu la tique les bains constructa
tradition ne va rester que c'est moderne
j'adore cuisiner dis moi je fais des
trucs simples pourquoi ses potes c'est
quoi ton plat le bloc qui fait tes potes
le poulet grillé et commentez le gri-gri
jeu le griot faux et je peux te dire le
talent pour quatre personnes moi je
j'aime j'aime mon poulet à lire toutes
les 10 minutes je sors du four et je le
badigeonne tu m'étonnes et bien faire un
poulet il faut aimer son poulet mais en
même temps même mort même mort faut
aimer le poulet j'te jure vous aimez
vivante si on n'aime pas la cuisine
qu'on fait ne sera pas bonne et due mais
rien d'autre que le poulet ou rouler
pleins de beurre
goegebuer alors beurre résille asie et
tu veux des déserts va peser les a pas
d'herbe pas d un que du beurre un poulet
fermier un boulet bien sûr élevé au
grain elle vous grain au grand chose
mais pas un grand récit non l'audio
grande halle aux grains et du beurre et
lacs et du beurre combien de beurre je
vais la moitié des 250 grammes à lèvres
des plumes
est au four et je me mets au four et je
leur réponds toutes les dix minutes l'om
sel à cette fleur de sel leur de lord of
the world
[Musique]
la cuisson pour que la course soit bien
doré mais toutes les dix minutes qui
vient peu arrosée et je la semence
rouleront cet animal mort
ça va atterrir parfait
de bonne humeur
tu me voilà très bien je vois bien ouais
là c'est là la sto va moins bien
baïla ils allaient là je te vois bien
n'a pas beaucoup il à 2,75 le pauvre et
3 l'autre
c'est augmenter un petit peu
a été à deux doigts du labrador la
cantine et interprète d quand tu fais
des combats on donne d épée en bois au
début un c'est vrai des épées en place
qui traiterait géo des légers il peut
faire mal puis on boira là et puis après
ça devient on une fois que j'ai bien
compris les mouvements on me donne un
peu de métal léger et après on donne du
vrai métal vrai métal ça fait
généralement très peur aux mecs qui en
face parce que là j'ai pas mes lunettes
paix
mais ça s'est toujours bien passé
et alors et et quand vous conduisez
christophe c'est pareil sur ce bout et
par exemple saviez pas quand il fallait
freiner quoi voilà exactement le premier
jour de tournage j'ai mal calculé à
distance parce que j'avais pas mes
lunettes et je me suis payé une barrière
en métal qui a bloqué la voiture et je
suis passé à travers le pare-brise et
j'ai failli tuer luc besson le chef
opérateur carlo varini parce qu'ils
étaient collés à la barrière et je suis
sorti de la voiture en regardant comme
ça c'est en dessous et luc m'a regardé
et m'a fait bouche surtout pas
christophe assieds-toi si toi doucement
quel mec je me dis qu'est ce qu'il est
les bars joue quoi moi ça va très bien
je m'étais pas rendu compte que j'étais
passé de l'autre côté du pare brise et
j'ai regardé mon costume et j'étais
couvert de sang eh ben ça c'était le
premier jour de 20 semaines de tournage
avec catherine barma qui voudrait savoir
pourquoi vous n'avez pas de lentilles
parce que ça lui fait les yeux violets
son chien je suis allergique à la
lentille pour combien de personnes
mes lentilles mais j'adore les landes
fait quoi comme viande à combien le
l'entrecôte et jeu mais j'adore le
saucisson de lyon ah oui c'est bon ça le
petit la lépi la zone antilles ta
méthode pour guérir la grille parce que
moi j'étais en ramant m'a dit écoute à
une méthode très simple attends je me
souviens plus passionnés combien way du
verre d'eau l'air et tu mets 5 6 gousses
d'ail cru à cette coutume ans josiane
que je donnerai qu'un petit elle vous
dira non on parle tout le temps des
filles des antibiotiques des machins et
ben ça tu prends ça quant à la grippe
bon c'est vrai que pour ceux qui sont
très agréables pas plus personne âgée
c'est après deux copains n'y a plus rien
qui peut crever après
ça t'enlève la chaîne il a plein de
recettes comme ça c'est un garçon et les
hémorroïdes non ça c'est pas
bien alors christophe lambert est ici ce
soit pour un film dont tout le monde
parle qui s'appelle janis et john un
film de samuel benchetrit avec vous
sergi lopez françois cluzet jean louis
trintignant et marie trintignant sortie
le 15 octobre voilà c'est un scénario
assez créatif que je vais essayé de
restituer alors sergi lopez joue le rôle
d'un agent d'assurance qu'une existence
assez banale avec sa femme qui est jouée
par marie trintignant et leurs enfants
voient là et pour arrondir ses fins de
mois sergi lopez entre l'agent
d'assurances escroqué un client il
empoche les primes sans assurer la
voiture de collection de son client
évidemment le malheur arrive la voiture
à un accident enfin que j'en dis pas
plus et elle n'est pas assurée alors lui
il faut qu'il trouve les cinq cent mille
balles que coûte cette bagnole ou alors
il va en taule et heureusement son
cousin qui est jouée par christophe
lambert qui s'appelle léon vient
d'hériter d'un million de francs mais le
problème c'est que les ont ils appris un
incident 73
descendu et jamais redescendre et il est
allé chercher c'est le cas de le dire ne
sont plus dans le film ils montent comme
ça il est perché c'est ce qu'on appelle
les hanches et la faune sur sa siège du
collège louis en plus c'est vrai il
connaît au plafond accès tout à fait
juste il n'est jamais redescendu et
quand il a pris cet acide dans les
chiottes d'une salle de concert il a vu
rentrer john lennon et janis joplin qui
lui ont dit on reviendra donc seul et on
ça fait 30 ans qu'il attend comme ça que
janis joplin et john lennon reviennent
et à ce moment là comment l'agent
d'assurances qui sait ça se dit mais
c'est formidable je vais déguiser
un comédien qui est jouée par cusey ans
john lennon et je vais déguisé ma femme
marie trintignant en janis joplin voilà
pour aller soutirer l'héritage de léon
c'est un scénario très créatif ceci je
suis très fier c'est drôle c'est ce qui
m'a plu quand j'ai rencontré samuel qui
m'a raconté l'histoire le scénario
n'était pas écrit et je lui ai dit c'est
tellement original c'est tellement
différent il ya un ton de comédie bien
évidemment parce que tu meures mehdi et
puis il ya aussi le côté l'univers naïf
enfantin que ce personnage de léon qui
lui est bloqué dans une bulle comme un
enfant qui croit au père mais ça lui
janis joplin john lennon lui ont dit on
reviendra avec les attend voilà est bon
il ya toute l'histoire de larmes c'est
rarement françaises et des scénarii
aussi
drôle en fait j'ai aussi moderne quoi
c'est plutôt un bon c'est vrai c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a séduit on regarde à
quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
voiture comme ça il vaut mieux laisser
dormir au garage mais alors pourquoi
vous voulez la soirée tous risques sait
jamais
[Musique]
cinq cent mille francs heureusement que
je suis assurée
dit heureusement que je suis assuré à la
police un chiffre en gros tout le monde
sait ça alors comment on va faire tu te
souviens de mon cousin vinny celle qui a
touché un héritage d'amylin ok il ne vit
que pour janis joplin et john lennon
mais alors qu'est ce que tu veux faire
vous aimez bien que j'en ai dans ce cas
comment imaginer yoko ono
la liste on vous jette prenons parfait
si tu crois que je vais me déguiser
angeli jockin et vous laisse à 100 mais
froide au plu à guy pearce
et l'escroquerie c'est vrai mais bon il
ya toujours le rôle parce que ça me
ferait du bien de faire un personnage
historique
[Musique]
hello my name is janis joplin je suis au
foot et quand il était anglais neil
hannon écoute je suis sûr qu'elle est
mort parle à tous j'aurais pu prendre
n'importe qui pour jésus nous
voilà dans le budget
non
personne ne critique mons travail
d'acteur
à
un plus haut à
ces
jeux là sur jeannie surplus
sa plus grande à mon avis c'est inchangé
wadja nissan jeune samuel benchetrit
gentilles 15 octobre dans un cinéma près
de chez vous évidemment
évidemment on va beaucoup parler du
dernier film tourné par marie
trintignant on va beaucoup dire que
c'est son ex samuel benchetrit qui l'a
réalisé mais je trouve que ça serait un
peu dommage voilà parce que c'est un
film qui mérite vraiment même s'il
n'était pas arrivé ce qui est arrivé
c'est un film qui mérite vraiment
beaucoup d'attention je trouve que je
crois je crois je crois surtout que ce
qui est ce qui est beau c'est que quoi
qu'il arrive et dans toute l'horreur de
ce qui s'est passé marie qui est
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement solaire
est extrêmement épanouie qui était
heureuse qui est joie de vivre
extraordinaire eh ben ils continuent à
la communiquer à travers ça et moi c'est
tout ce que je retiens c'est à dire pour
moi à travers ça elle vit et elle fait
rire elle fait pleurer un film
magnifique quelles que soient les choses
qui sont arrivées c'est un film
magnifique c'est un film qui reste il ya
d'abord une bonne histoire c'est
ressuscité deux morts du rox quand même
un truc qui nous touche c'est bon c'est
normal bon la réalisation est très
créative avec un moment l'image s'arrête
et on entend des commentaires face et
s'est très c'est très moderne la lumière
est excellente les acteurs plus en
lennon il est assez vite assez bon état
c'est crédible il fait il lui ressemble
c'est un très très bon casting enfin
c'est pas lennon c'est un acteur raté
qui se prend pour les jeunes c'est pour
ça que c'est drôle vous vous avez le
look ziggy stardust
ouais ouais au début ce que çe ailleurs
a complètement il est comme comme ce que
je te disais c'est c'est un mec qui
croient au père noël est un et on peut
pas le décrocher de ça et je trouve ça
beau mais moi j'avais rencontré un pote
à l'école qui est resté scotché sur la
cdi balayer la cour ont ré et moi je
savais pas je n'avais jamais pris
d'acide et j'en ai jamais pris
d'ailleurs j'avais peur de la petite
pilule comme ça il conçoit le film je
comprends et et le mec il était resté
bloqué sur son acide et il balayait plus
que la couronne ouais ouais donc je sais
pas sur quoi il peut rester bloquée ou à
quel moment et erratique bloqué mais en
tout cas ça devait avoir quelque chose
avec un balai une cour parce que
affaire
seront alors voilà on a souvent parlé de
vos conquêtes et là je crois que ça y
est je crois vous êtes rangé des
voitures moins chères sur est très
heureux ouais 13 évidence alors il est
interdit aux ménages puis 3 c'est bien
parce que chaque petite photo avec josy
way stop là
ça fait pas un
heureusement tu bosses pas apprécié
parce qu'il était très grand chose en
prouverture
n'ont donc je suis passé j'ai un
problème j'ai été mariée deux fois je
dis ça pour les plus jeunes qui ont pas
suivi toutes les aventures de monsieur
lambert donc une première fois avec
diane lane et ensuite avec j'ai misé
afte et là bientôt donc un troisième
mariage avec sophie desmarais qui est la
fille d'un magnat canadien ça y est
c'est réglé elle est géniale quand on
rencontre son âme soeur faut pas la
louper alors ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que quand vous l'avez rencontré
quand vous l'avez vu pour la première
fois elle venait d'avoir un cancer du
cerveau elle avait le crâne rasé elle
était très fatiguée elle voulait pas
sortir quand vous l'avez vu arriver vous
avez dit on dirait un ange vous êtes
tombé amoureux d'elle ouais oui bon on a
on a on a commencé à parler on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait que des choses en
commun ouais et c'est vrai que je pense
que les gens qui subissent des choses
extrêmement profonde extrêmement
douloureuses comme une tumeur au cerveau
comme n'importe quelle maladie qui peut
être fatale ont des gens qui ont une
réflexion différente une vision
différente de la vie et qui généralement
l'apprend apprennent avec énormément de
positif positif pour activisme est ce
qu'elle est au courant de de votre vie
amoureuse avant bras vous savez moi je
peux pas cacher mon passé non mais vous
l'avez donc à la rassure moi tu as
triché sur les chiffres
non mais à partir du moment où on aime
quelqu'un il n'y a pas de mensonge
j'avais une très mauvaise réputation
excellente au contraire quand on voit la
liste est pas non non mais j'ai pas
radine de match il de fontenay
il a fait chaud tout le monde j'avais
rien à cacher je sers je me dis que
sophie rigole en coulisse donc merci
serge je vais pouvoir égrainer la liste
ça va on peut y aller sophie bien alors
oui je t'écoute non alors bon bah non
c'est une liste extraordinaire stéphanie
de monaco ouais mais ça c'est super tu
le saches pas c'était très discrète
jamais une photo un premier eu des films
ouais mais dans une cache et se dit
grand manteau est d'ailleurs d'un bon
d'accord
konchesky ad les rats ouais elle était
basilan je t'écoute l'après-vie
milliardaire israélienne un peu moins
connu mais très vite nina steven ouais
ouais bon c'est vrai mais
n'était pas aussi milliardaire que ça je
crois que c'était son set et son ex mari
qui était
sur moi j'avais des gros nichons comme
je me souviens tout ça c'était les
choses
c'était des choses de très courte durée
c'est à dire béatrice dalle savait pas
d'idées ouais ouais ouais et voici joey
starr
bon bah je te tends ya encore cinq ans
et l entarteur qui sait faire
tourner les enfants non mais
sérieusement en plus alors ce qui est
formidable chez vous si vous là je vous
fait passer pour un séducteur mais ce
n'est pas du tout en fait vous êtes un
affectif ouais puis je suis pas du tout
un dragueur du tout c'est vrai qu'on a
besoin d'amour tu as besoin d'un moment
en essayant de trop la trouver c'est là
qu'elle n'arrive pas et c'est pour ça
que j'ai eu plein de petites aventures
et aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé ce livre il
est pauvre non non ah non c'est des
photos truquées que j'ai ah ouais
non mais oui quand tu as trouvé ta
trouver tu le sentais bien
pour toujours jamais été aussi haut
comme ça donc pourquoi je vais le
changer bien est content pour moi mais
je suis très content je suis content
aussi pour sophie mais personne n'y
croit
que ça va durer les jours non bah non
mais ça fait déjà deux ans et demi oui
ils auront déjà ils se sont trompés ça
va durer encore les jours c'est ce que
voulait dire les gens
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire à sophie
parce que je crois que là haut pour
autant d vaut mieux tout dire christophe
beaucoup d' aventure mais des aventures
passagères essence en conséquence sans
conséquence non et puis aussi ça va se
drogue pas mal de drogue et non c'est
non
3 si on veut parler si on veut parler
des choses des choses qui sont
différentes des drogues n'ont jamais
vraiment à de l'alcool ouais mais ça oui
mais ça j'ai complètement arrêté de
boire depuis trois mois dans
complètement arrêté plus une goutte
ouais c'est bien chapon pas vrai c'est
vachement
ribéry on a des tentations partout
encore un alcoolique célèbre wii
catherine bach ou qu'elle nous rejoigne
attend non mais tu as maintenant station
au point où on en est je crois que là
maintenant on a tout mis sur la table on
ira jusqu'au bout moi je veux que cette
liaison se construit sur des bases
solides catherine je préfère que ce
fille des marais soit là qu'on met tout
à plat et puis tant pis on va y passer
la nuit ici il faut mais mais je pense
que demain matin on aura résolu le
problème à barsac
[Musique]
ja
sophie je suis content que vous soyez là
parce que là on est en train de tout
mettre à plat comme vous l'avez bien
compris donc tout ce qui est aventure on
l'a fait là on en était à la drogue on
verra l'homosexualité avec laurent c'est
un dossier c'est un beau succès confirmé
ce que je peux dire que le polo est
trouvée non ce n'est pas un truc
bien non la drogue c'est vrai allergique
aux pétards complet alors d'armes n'ont
même pas quand même non il ya eu quand
même il faut bien le dire je crois que
c'est important de le dire en présence
de celui il ya quand même quelques
expériences de drogue dure un certain
moment non je crois qu'on peut
dire s'il fait vraiment des experts
l'expérience c'est à dire en fin de
compte autant je pouvait boire beaucoup
autant les drogues ne mangea j'ai jamais
été addictif foudre ouais c'est un
épiphénomène
c'est ce que le message sur son avocat
non mais est-ce que alors maintenant est
ce que c'est vrai qu'il a arrêté de
boire parce que ça c'est une drogue
aussi c'est sans doute la pire est ce
que c'est vrai qu'il a arrêté de boire
depuis deux trois mois ap sa première
fois à la télé donc
c'est facile mais rapsim la coupe et
mary t il arrêter de boire campe élevé
mieux depuis en pda et toujours été
géniale mais là on a sûrement mieux
maintenant absolument un non mais c'est
vrai que ça change je le veux dire c'est
à dire aux gens ce que j'allais devenir
c'est bon j'ai pas arrêté de fumer parce
que je peux pas tout arrêter en même
temps mais en fin de compte les drogues
les réelles drogues les plus difficiles
à arrêter sont les drogues est en vente
libre ouais l'alcool et la clope voilà
ce que la clope c'est l'achat
remboursé par la sécu remercier pascal
talmon bref si tu veux c'est vraiment
non mais c'est bizarre c'est bizarre les
plus gros consommateurs de
tranquillisants d'europe bravo non mais
c'est vrai
parce que là on va arriver
difficile évidemment de l'interview se
fit blindés vous je crois qu'il faut que
vous soyez blindés
quand on regarde la filmographie de fut
christophe lambert assez incertain pour
tous est un petit peu une auberge
espagnole
évidemment les trucs énormes évidemment
les cristaux qui à paroles et musique à
ce brouillage länder mais il ya aussi
hercules et sherlock banon mais je me
suis bien marré revient ce film away il
a bien géré la la j'ai fait pour ma
petite fille ouais ouais ça a bien
marché berceau ouais puis j'adore
tourner akrich ah non moi je me souviens
des pieds alors je crois je sais pas
s'il vous l'a dit il a tourné dans
vercingétorix et lé courage un courage
de vous le dire est-ce qu'il a eu le
courage de vous le dire non mais elle le
savait elle le savait et alors jamais vu
mais c'est pour ça vous êtes encore avec
lui ah non mais ça c'est bien
bien des cas ça sera coupé non bon alors
non un nom vercingétorix ça a été une
expérience extrêmement difficile pour
une raison c'est qu'à un moment donné
quand on fait un film épique un
personnage qui est aussi important que
vercingétorix
c'est vachement agréable pour un acteur
de se dire je vais interpréter
vercingétorix quand tout à coup au
milieu d'un tournage on s'aperçoit qu'il
n'a pas le pognon nécessaires pour faire
un pli le film épique et des choses
comme ça c'est extrêmement difficile
pour les acteurs pour les techniciens
pour le metteur en scène de mettre tout
son coeur dedans parce qu'on a continué
à mettre son coeur dans ce film en
sachant qu'au résultat final ça sera
peut-être pas à la hauteur alors je
voudrais que le public vote est ce que
vous êtes d'accord qu'on regarde ça au
montage non
voilà ce sera gardée monde moi je suis
désolé sur vercingétorix la hausse pas
j'étais sauveteur en parler
tu veux que je lis les critiques non tu
veux maintenant je les connais par coeur
tu rien alors je vais te dire en parlant
des critiques eh ben je vais te dire une
chose la critique positif que c'est
génial donc il vaut mieux passer dessus
la critique négative moi j'ai beaucoup
appris en lisant les critiques parce que
en fin de compte dans tout le négatif
qui avait les gens disaient mais comment
ce qu'un mec comme ça peut faire ça ça
veut dire comme donc je peux faire mieux
eh ben ça m'a appris des choses et je me
suis dit maintenant tu vas faire mieux
mais c'est tout et quand des gens comme
samuel m'ont proposé janis et john et où
on sent que c'est mieux on sent que
c'est deviendra mais la toile non mais
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est comme
ça qu'on apprend je romps fait des
erreurs et moi je ne justifie jamais mes
erreurs j'en ai fait je vis avec et puis
c'est comme ça c'est pas gentil pour
t'accompagner mais non mais ça c'est
benoît médiapart y a pas d'erreur pour
le non à coup de messages pour dire que
ta femme est très très belle et que vous
allez très bien ensemble et par semaine
juste un monsieur qui te demandes si ça
fait pas un peu débordé l'accent
québécois a pas du tout j'adore j'adore
j'adore
bien des pervers
alors à ça on est relié mais il n'y a
pas de ville
en dehors du cinéma christophe lambert
vous êtes un excellent businessman
producteur de films
viticulteurs restaurateurs hôteliers et
puis aussi puis aussi une usine de deux
places toujours ça ouais ouais mais ça
existe toujours on a on a recommandé la
barre du parti dia du fuel est
il ya des côtelettes d'agneau il ya du
magret de canard mais aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il ya des barquettes individuelles ou
essaient de défense de personnes
l'agencé bien habiter ta copine ou tongs
pensez pas
et moi qui décide un malaisien
mais cela c'est un mec qui est vraiment
qui connaît l'agroalimentaire qui
s'occupe de ça et puis moi je fais de
l'immobilier puis je fais des trucs
alors dans cette usine là de deux places
ou vide là ils font les 35 heures ben je
vais te dire ils sont obligés de les
fermer y en a plein qui aimeraient en
faire plus mais moi j'ai toujours été
depuis longtemps j'ai toujours pensé que
les 35 heures n'étaient pas une logique
pour l'économie d'un pays mais vous avez
déclaré excusez moi les 35 heures je les
fais en une journée en deux jours parce
qu en une journée c'est dur c'était un
gag kadhafi il est allé à ping bravo et
j'aime travailler j'aime travailler mais
parce que je dois pas ça et j'ai la
chance de faire un métier où j'ai pas
l'impression je travaille comme ceux qui
travaillent dans son usine tu comprends
que déjà 35 heures c'est long il ya des
gens qui auraient travaillé plus il ya
des gens qui sont tout seuls chez eux
qui se dit je préfère travailler plutôt
que de m'emmerder à la maison dont le
toit était content quoi voilà dit le
sait pas c'est pas que je suis content
je suis pour que les gens fassent ce
qu'ils ont envie de dire je dirais
d'avoir dit et c'est pas une question de
politique de gauche ou de droite d'avoir
dit que les 35 heures à les ramener de
l'emploi et de reparler de ça en disant
que ça a créé 330000 oui sacré 330 mille
fonctionnaires qui sont payés par nous
au niveau des impôts 1 c'est pas ça crée
de l'emploi c'est tout et j'ai toujours
pensé que c'était un travail ou 38
heures qu'ils soient beaux ou trois
heures de plus dans la semaine qu'est ce
qu'ils pensent de l'exode rural d'un
point de vue alors manon mais voilà qui
regarde mon poulet y mange du grimp qui
vient de la campagne donc moi je trouve
que la ruralité c'est très bien c'est
très bien il faut aussi que ces villages
qui se désintéresse jour j'aurai vu
d'école n'ont plus de boulot il faut
leur rendre il faut leur donner
largement concrètement mais comment
concrètement en angola
faut pas tout vient de la nature bon bah
de la campagne c'est la nature est de
systématiquement l'éliminer c'est la
plus grosse erreur qu'on fasse et
l'euthanasie
est un nazi ça devrait être le choix
d'une famille le choix du patient si un
mec il a envie de mourir parce qu'il a
un cancer généralisé qui souffre mille
morts c'est son problème et l'heure
d'été bon
il a pas d'avis sur l'heure d'été
alors que son coeur va terminer josiane
l'heure d'été les oreilles cette maison
alors mais j'ai parfois du mal avec
l'heure d'été voilà on va changer c'est
un truc on se réveille on n'est pas bien
même pour le moral voile - soleil aux
heures d'été moi je suis mort moi tu me
parles plus
bien alors que certains verts vous êtes
acteur de films d'action en même temps
un homme de coups on vient de le voir
dans tous ses différentes activités et
avec ce film qui oscille donc maintenant
on va faire la moue dernier coup
[Musique]
customer
dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de tête partir en bateau ou
en grèce a séché ou en grèce dans toute
la gamme nikon au nom d'une ville soit
mykonos j'étais avec ma femme ces bons
coups de coeur je t'ai vu mais pareil
qu'une femme peut couper les
pirates ont tenté par un dernier coup de
coeur mais se fait bronzer 20 minutes
sur le ventre les boîtes et deux
semaines
je veux dire à tous que plus jamais
qu'on parle de ça prouvait que sur
levante là bas alors dernier coup de
coeur afin bien les coups de gueule
dernier coup de gueule je suis quelqu'un
d'extrêmement
calme un patient mais je suis pas de
l'art du tout c'est à dire je m'adapte
je te ferai novartis dit ce dernier coup
de butoir
est là où partir se fichent de fresnes à
mort a sinon il va effet grossier un
dernier coup de fil à leurs derniers
coups de fil vrai ou le vrai dernier
coup de fil que ta place après un
dernier coup de fil
à samuel et aux producteurs de
janis et john pour savoir comment ça se
passait en avignon où ils sont en ce
moment et ça se passe bien et ça se
passe à salé bois il ya des gens sur les
marches d'escalier tout baigne c'est
génial dernier coup de rouge passé il ya
deux mois de mai dernier coup de rouge
c'était il ya deux mois et demi dans les
coups de bluff c'est la théorie sur le
roux la fin
d'année coups de soleil ah j'adore non
j'adore le soleil de la présente comme
entité mais je me mets jamais au soleil
d'accord ces deux matches je mets de la
crème est ce que tu es passionné et en
plus je rougis donc c'est bizarre voire
et un écran total par exemple je t'aime
sol est quand même dans même way et à
l'ombre à l'ombre d'un et coup de bol
dernier coup de bol d'avoir rencontré
samuel et d'avoir fait james et au
niveau de ma carrière au niveau de ma
vie sophie dahl et coups de blues bien
les coups de blues quand quand je buvais
beaucoup et que ses recettes ça me
faisait du mal à ma vie ouais ils se
mettaient les lélés les cassettes de
vingt cinq normales
j'aurais pas dû y faire ses
derniers coups de cul
ouais non non
d'en découdre à
autre chose yann un peu enfin
makoun dernier coudre à
bagnac ya quatre jours parce que je suis
arrivé il ya trois jours que tu le fais
pas je t'ai africaine à part dont on
comprend
avec marie trintignant françois cluzet
chercher jean louis trintignant
voyez vous coucher là elle va revenir
quand elle veut parce que leurs cartes
de bonnes clientes bien aussi
car de vos clients permettent de revenir
alors même quand on n'a pas de promo
sûrement envie de boire un coup en plus
c'est qu'on fait avec tu reviens quand
tu veux tiens cela
tu reviens quand tu es c'est bien bon à
tirer
au fait il a joué sur les contraire en
fait bien merci josiane merci sophy vous
vous l'attendez vous voulez rester c'est
comme vous voulez je voulais rester
c'est la bienvenue non je crois que je
vais retourner à ma classe la black hat
bravo très sympa non non la liste
christophe
l'homosexualité vous restez finalement
un bon je devais partir mais tu pars pas
en partance
attend là
écoute yan wei and mail rappelle on le
rappelle josé m oui si josiane d'avoir
le même onze sorties
oui
[Musique]
bordeaux n'est pas rien
c'est toi
à ce moment on avait le droit de revenir
à laver la carte oui bon revenir quand
elle veut on la rappelle on l'appelle jr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense que l'or est content
mais je pense qu'on a laissé camping non
non josie ho non ça
on a des séquences de bing pour charger
tout à leurs assurés ça c'est collector
dans 20 ans ils repasseront la
sécheresse
l'accès allez bon à la suite
[Musique]
ah ouais si diane de france
m
ancien de france bonsoir heureux de vous
avoir sur le plateau de tout le monde en
parle
la fia peut être désagréable tout à
l'heure en personne mais désagréable
merci chez vous
[Applaudissements]
dit voilà c'est bien de laisser une
place entre vous deux social un
bien alors jen de france princesse
d'orléans duchesse de wurtemberg
stéphane bern vous consacre un ouvrage
publié chez flammarion et qui s'intitule
jane de france la princesse rebelle
voilà donc nous avons en effet nous
avons avec nous une rebelle
avant
no
pas la babouche bien vous êtes né le
dimanche de pâques 1940 au brésil car
votre père le comte de paris devant la
montée de la guerre par la montée des
périls avait envoyé toute la famille au
brésil pour la mettre à l'abri voilà et
vous tenez un petropolis exactement à
quelque 100 bornes de rio de janeiro
c'est ça c'est dans la montagne c'est un
peu le versailles brésilien est un peu
petit en comparaison j'y suis allé
c'était très beau cette cause voilà
c'est là qu'habite et les empereurs du
brésil voilà alors votre maire et elle a
donc déjà quand vous êtes arrivé et
parce que votre mère et situe elle m'a
tenté j'ai l'impression que
c'est d'habitude
[Applaudissements]
et comme à l'habitude c'est un bel est
super sympa on en a eu d'étude portée
mais
vous naissez à petropolis dans le
versailles brésilien j'espère que mes
amis téléspectateurs qui regardent cette
émission pour se cultiver suivre ce que
je dis regarde sur la carte ou et
petropolis absolument alors quand la
guerre commence votre père s'engage
incognito dans la légion étrangère sous
le nom de orliac mais il est démobilisé
évidemment en 40 quand il ya l'armistice
et s'installe au maroc où il devient
l'héritier du trône de france à la mort
de son propre père c'est comme ça que ça
se passe voit à l'époque la loi d'exil
interdit aux familles ayant régné sur la
france de vivre en france donc vous êtes
en exil un au maroc vous est élevé comme
une espèce de petite sauvageonne on
pourrait dire mais je crois que je ne
t'ai pas élevé je crois que c'était dans
le mois mais c'est d'être sauvage
mais c'est pas l'éducation n'a pas été
sauvageonne du tout oui on a une
éducation très stricte ce qui est très
bien pour plus tard mais je crois que
c'est mon caractère qui sortait de la
cgt intitulé par tous de la famille la
sauvagerie sauvage auxdits peu le vilain
petit canard oui j'en ai mal léché un
doudou tu vas y venir
salut à toi
donc vous vivez au maroc cette prime
enfance ensuite l'espagne à pampelune et
le portugal dans la maison de votre père
la cuenta voilà il l'a
garé là vous entré en rébellion contre
pratiquement la terre entière et vous
dites très jeune personne ne décidera à
ma place la couleur de mes pulls un
jeu dit textuellement une piscine psy
qui était venu me voir je dis personne
ne désire pas à partir d'aujourd'hui ce
que je vais faire de ma vie et moi je
dessine moi même je vais faire c'est ça
qui m'a
que la psy n'étais pas très contente pas
très longtemps d'ailleurs alma cul du
monde de l'époque j'étais punie bref
vous a été puni
à dire que tellement diane était et
rebelles
après le passage chez la psy
effectivement on l'a mis dans une
institution pour handicapés mentaux oui
bah oui parce que tu veux la à cette
époque là ça rigolait pas une seconde
alors ouais ça fait tout à fait les
collèges de rich and roses et les roms
si cela fait six mois qu'on n'est pas
des institutions pour handicapés mentaux
non là mais j'ai fréquenté aussi chance
voilà et la moitié des enfants qui
étaient incapables de reconnaître une
pomme d'un char oui oui j'avais beaucoup
de thèmes pour ceux des battus à coups
de bâtons oui alors moi je prenais les
coups de bâton pour parce que j'avais
trop de peine mais une petite fille de 9
ans qui prend des coups de bâton pour
les autres ça dure une deux semaines et
après je dis moi je veux plus continuer
à prendre des coups de bâton mais ça me
faisait de la peine alors à l'issue de
ce séjour dans cette institution pour
handicapés mentaux 1 vous rompez
carrément avec votre famille vous ne
voulait plus les voir non je le vois
mais ça m'était complètement et la
compagnie
étant donné qu'on est on a un timbre sur
nous
on décrète et imbécile l'idiot moi je
dis pas c'est très bien à partir
d'aujourd'hui moi je fais encore plus
que jeux et à partir de là vous êtes
très bien j'étais les bancs des
domestiques abu rahma madelon madeleine
était adorable venait du limousin je lui
chante et la madelon et non c'était pas
très correct non plus 18 princesse diana
non c'est pas ça elle m'a éduquée est
adorable et j'allais avec les ouvriers
dans la ferme aux fonges fiche est rien
il est élevé par les domestiques et en
1950 l'assemblée nationale abroge la loi
d'exil vous rentrez en france oui je
finis par un prêt il l'a quand vous
allez dans une école française vous êtes
victime alors là du passé historique de
votre famille dans la cour d'école les
enfants vous crie orléans assassin oui
oui oui oui alors moi j'étais furieux je
me suis dit comment est ce qu'ils
peuvent oser dire que mon père est un
assassin enfin la porte et tout ce qui
s'est passé des rois de france mais je
trouve que c'était injuste c'est
justement une fois j'ai vu un panneau
une envolée en 80 kilomètres je n'y ai
pas cru
c'est plus court
ça choque quand même c'est pas les
dénonciations tout le temps
faut dire les choses faire les choses
l'ancêtre que diane philippe égalité a
voté la mort de son cousin louis saez je
sais pas si toi tu voterais la mort de
ton cousin oui non
non ils regardent pas sûr non base non
voilà non tu vois là et ensuite louis
philippe a chassé charles dit son cousin
les deux fois de suite mais il
s'entendait pas très bien la corde il a
chassé du trône c'est vrai qu'à l'école
vous tombiez sur vous
rien lounge disait mon jeune fils disait
arrêter de dire des bêtises pareilles en
face c'est vrai mais vous n'avez pas
besoin d'attaquer le nom de mon père moi
je défende et quand même mon père mais
vous comprenez quand même que que des
enfants et puis vous dire ça allez ça se
comprend c'est les parents qui le rendit
ça c'est pas le parent qu'il était
partisan aucun petit l'arrangerait savez
c'est un espèce de stupidité de la liste
on compte les enlève enfin voilà en tous
les cas vous êtes fait insulter à
l'école et qu'est ce que vous faites de
19 ans vous épousez habache épouse dit
voilà c'est quoi votre frère a dit
puisque l'utah aussi épouse inge van den
berg votre frère henri qu'est donc
maintenant l'héritier du trône a dit que
c'était des mariages arrangés tout ça au
départ non c'est absolument pas vrai
avant lui il était fou amoureux de la
liste ça je peux vous le dire parce que
quand on en a l'air en chemin il fallait
s'arrêter pour téléphoner à cette époque
avait parlé mais ma belle sachs rappelle
marie thérèse alors c'était les poêler
et moi j arrête de téléphoner fiche nous
la payons maintenant nous là où on
verrait donc en fait c'est pas vrai
maintenant votre mariage n'a pas été
arrangé on va y trouviez pas ce que vous
savez bien quand même je sais à aider à
la réconciliation franco allemand ça
fait ça fait d un bout de gaulle
adenauer c'est leur fait plaisir de voir
que dès que des
moyens les aristocrates français épouse
et des ruisseaux craint tellement
c'était bien ouais ouais c'était très
bien pour la pour la france et
l'allemagne pour la paix au métal oui
mais vous non même si les premiers oui
oui c'était par amour c'est par amour
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous habiller en elton john en quoi
six enfants oui
je continue je peux je peux continuer
laurent alors le problème quand même
faut le dire c'est que la vie chez les
vertes hennebert que c'était pas très
très très drôle c'est pas facile à
prononcer déjà ça c'était pas vrai vol
mais avec mon humour moins brillé oui
bon je vais jamais un truc c'est que la
nuit de noces vous arrivez à zurich il
n'avait pas réservé une chambre d'hôtel
on a fait tout oublier franchement vous
étiez vous êtes dormir dans un bouge oui
oui
mais ça fait rire c'est là vous êtes
formidable ça vous a fait rire sa tête
pour trouver dans un boui boui ça vous
oblige
à retrouver toute la famille en aéroport
de nouveau deux embrassades bon
législature le mec les y avait mais vous
voyez de ma vie il ya eu des choses de
ce livre montre que c'est une femme qui
a passé par des hauts et des bas
terrible mais à chaque fois grâce à son
humour c'est vrai ça c'est vrai et elle
rigole de la plus importante des bêtises
qu'on me faisait des mauvaises jeanine
aux ouvriers oui j'en ai moi ça s'est
bien passé ça vous regarde ses
abonnements payants mais ça s'est bien
passé dans
le livre ah c'est vous qui l'avez
croquis
au fusain fait pour vous plus intimes
comme dans titanic
bien alors aprilia il ya un épisode un
petit peu tragique sérieusement c'est le
voyage de noces donc vous êtes à rio
vous rencontrez une diseuse de bonne
aventure qui vous qui vous tire qui vous
tient les cartes et qui vous annoncent
la mort de votre frère françois qui est
mort en héros en algérie on s'en
souvient tous et c'est un petit peu le
début du déclin la famille de relais on
peut le dire quoi là la mort françois
est un grand choc pour nous tous aussi
moi aussi c'était mon héros comme jeudi
dan et là vous découvrez un peu comme
votre père quoi ça faisait très déçu par
votre père présent pillay il avait
promis une dot pour vous il l'a pas payé
cette ville turque on ne voit on avoue
avoir de l'humour abîmé la situation de
ma belle famille on verra avec normal
home est ce très bien très bien très
bien ça donnerait une dot et puis j'en
ai jamais vu la couleur bon avec 1 1
million de fonds qui avait été promis
par votre père il avait guidé donnerait
en date c est
le nom ce qui s'est passé d'ancien
annuel qui a été obligé de s'appuyer le
dit vachement bien la famille de
wurtemberg est obligé de s'appuyer les
frais du mariage et henri votre père n'a
rien donné maintenant que vous quand
vous étiez face à cette famille
d'everton berges c'était très compliqué
pompiers c'était gênant on était un peu
comme un coucou qui viendra
c'est un peu embêtant d'ailleurs il vous
mènent la vie dure certaines berck c'est
pas facile pour vous et des problèmes
voilà
c'est la tienne vous partez c'est un
petit peu la boulette mais je crois
comme vous en pensez
en fait je crois que vous en parlait
dans liste donc on peut en parler c'est
un petit peu ça ça va vous réchauffer
tout parce que ça
alors nous on n'attaque personne non
simplement alors laurent tu sois tu sois
bon que tu sois au courant
diane parent seul en espagne j'ai lu le
livre quand elle part seule en espagne
ces congés payés à larreule à la phrase
j'ai trouvé le réconfort sur l' épaule
compatissante d'hommes
fusse-t-il rois princes ou simples
anonymes
êtes contents non n'est pas content non
mais pas celle à
victoria eugenia je me réjouis pas de ça
maintenant vous vous êtes un pur mais
oui bah c'est ma femme faisait ça m'a
dit que j'aurais pas l'attitude de karl
qui a passé les passants vous voyez
qu'on est revenu car va passer l'épongé
moi ma femme partirait en congés payés
comme vous dit avec des rois des princes
voire 2,5 reviennent que l pas pour
toujours je sais pas je ne sais pas
répond non je ne serai pas dépenses non
oui
tu sais il ya plein de trucs que tu sais
pas tiré
voilà qu'on se parle
vous avez de la chance permettez moi de
vous le dire j'ai eu la chance de tomber
sur un homme car lequel ne serait un
grandeur d'âme et choisit voulait bien
choisi crème de mec oui bien sûr il est
la même chez le panier
un grand seigneur
peut-être un jour vous l'aurez ici mais
j'espère c'est dommage qu'ils soient pas
venus alors oui mais là plein d'affaires
et quel couturier en plus
la guerre
berg
palais les fiches qui va stade désert
bordeaux qui passent l'épongé alors
alors au fait ils passent l'épongé on
pardonne
sans problème en combien de temps
par binta en dix minutes un jimmy ne va
pas se fatiguer je vois pas pourquoi
faire du blabla
[Rires]
pas moi je suis arrivé j'ai dit cook
voilà je reviens
il attend un peu râler il n'a pas dû
allaiter ou la pomponnette
s'écoute suis là tout le monde de tous
le tout le monde du château les enfants
tout le monde n'ont qu'une envie que je
revienne parce que il faut voir que
quand je suis parti les dames doivent le
savoir quand on quitte la maison ben
c'est le bordel après par la maison un
volume tout à vau l'eau et la gabegie
alors moi moi ils ont bien vu que
finalement je faisais quelque chose donc
il était assez content revenir
finalement à
une question il ne s'est pas dans le
livre ça c'est pas dans le livre est ce
que vous êtes reparti ensuite en congés
payés non ça c'est bien non non qui vous
a pardonné une fois mais après vous avez
fait jamais fait des cards jan bon
d'accord c'est bon ok c'est bon pas mal
toute façon elle était carrick d épaule
s'était pas oui oui déziel pour louis tu
as raison
en bâtissant
au même titre que celui-ci n'est
peut-être pas trompé une épaule on peut
dire que c'est pas grave une épaule
alors pourquoi par exemple
[Applaudissements]
il m'est polémique must die de l'eau
on était tous là c'est pas la peine
qu'on parle de ça oui par exemple c'est
quoi alors que ça non mais une belle
épaule d'agneau
ça c'est bon tu viens pas tuer des
patates humide
tout simple épaule d'agneau devions tous
gousse d'ail en chemise en jean chemise
voilà c'est à dire tu vois
c'est bon tu as la peau pack bien sûr
toujours avec un véhicule
bien donc voilà donc là laurent tu suis
la victoire dans un bouquin on s'en
remet ça sera dans les recettes de
taille
va pas falloir qu'ils les appliquent
tout parce qu'ils vont regarder surprise
à mes des bonnes souvent non mais des
choses simples diane pardon renom à
diane badiane s'est réglé donc au derby
de new line non non on attend on va
parler un peu de cuisine c'est quoi vos
haches et très courts châtains et les
yeux des cuisines ah non moi je fais une
passe jamais à noël 200 personnes pour
que le jem et est implantée dans parce
que mon truc à moi était de commencer
mon ménage en cuisinant très mal comme
ça au moins dix fois moins que ceux ci
oui c'est biographique maintenant il ya
toujours une cuisine mais moi je veux
leur dire qu'on va faire des choses mais
je veux pas passer la journée là
l'inspecteur des travaux finis touche
pas oui je vois pas pourquoi
bien sûr tant qu'il ya des gens pour le
faire passer
ouais j'aime cuisiner c'est tout je
suis et je voyage par exemple tu adaptes
est tellement tu vas après ingestion
voulait connaître les
soulèvements manger après
des mois ce que tu as à taper dans les
eaux cette québécoise là bas c'était
encore ils sont ses pensées
alors donc on irait alors vous savez on
en est oui donc karl part de jean pour
tous voilà d'ailleurs tiens à dire
excuse moi les sandwiches que vous avez
amené dans la chambre ils sont là
géniaux bravo le droit à
la vie dans la chambre non pas dans la
loge dans la neige je crois que c'est
une chambre alors allons-y donc alors là
les sandwichs elle avait des prénoms
et ça plaît
bien alors là là c'est le drame oui oui
comment tu le sais pas ce que tu l'as
bien introduit là là commencent les
querelles entre vos parents l'ex ionel
bien exemple ont remporté un exemple le
cas le reste
[Rires]
vous ne pouvez rien faire non mais
attends parlons de poulet il ya un
poulain extraordinaire excuse moi tu
réagis man s'appelle pas non non pardon
ça s'appelle poulet sodomie
alors non je vais vous dire un truc
c'est ça d'un koné si ça c'est pas des
trucs de cochon barbara c'est un truc de
poules tu mets une bouteille de bière
vide tu met de l'eau dedans tu mets ça
dans le truc du poulet ça s'appelle ce
demi tu sais que tu le mets quoi tu
poses le poulet dessus tu mets le poulet
dans le four et l'eau sort de la
bouteille comme vapeur et un bib un bide
n'y a plus de bière en bouteille et le
vide de bière ce que tu veux de
bouteilles en verre un vélo invite toute
la chair du poulet c'est extraordinaire
je te rappelle que le poulet est mineur
et s'attend ce coup de la loi car il est
23 jours
j'ai patienté spurs avec un poulet 23
sur
ses patins je regarde lamoureux
la nouveauté vient l'âge dans l'émission
régulièrement ce fait des bisous pour se
rassurer
[Applaudissements]
bien j'étais bien là le ricard de la
semaine dernière et a vu ça a laissé des
traces il faut faut partager ces moments
c'est des moments essentiels ouais alors
là commencement car elle sait tout ça
contient
on mène on gagne en tant que la langue
la josiane
là commencent les querelles donc entre
vos parents alors pour donner un exemple
des querelles entre les parents de diane
encontre le comte de paris et sa femme
quand votre père un accident cardiaque
votre mère dit prof tu ne gâchera
toujours nos vacances sympa et déjà
préparer une pièce mortuaire au cas où
il meurt mais sérieux c'est incroyable
moi j'étais la première à courir près de
papa ce point il m'a demandé que je
vienne jusqu'au moment laurent et là on
est en terrain de connaissance aussi on
a déjà beaucoup parlé dans cette
émission avec deux beaux frères donc
vous voyez déjà la colère se fait mettre
le grappin dessus par madame frise donc
monica et et vous dites dans votre
cuisine chez c'est l'infirmière avec qui
il vivait à chantilly le papa de diane
le comte de paris donc il vivait avec
cette infirmière il écoutait la valise
rtl pendant qu'elle passer la
serpillière on a déjà beaucoup parlé de
la scène et vous vous avez une phrase
qui est un petit peu de terry pour
madame frise qui est une infirmière qui
soulageait les messieurs fortunés et pas
seulement de leurs douleurs
oui c'est quand même explicite que cela
c'est explicit lyrics
21 explique moi parce que moi non je
n'ai pas de la leur
et
ben voilà ce qu'il faut dire maintenant
pour régler d'affaires voilà ses côtés
car le porte étendard de plein air c'est
vrai qu'il ya 50 ans la fortune d
orléans il ya cinquante ans quand ils
sont revenus d'exil a qui sont installés
à louveciennes la fortune d orléans
était de un milliard de nouveaux francs
1 tu imagines l'époque 50 ans
il y avait des il y avait des forces et
des projets des forêts non massif
des sourires les forêts y avait des
forêts quant à la norme mais c'est vrai
et aujourd'hui donc on peut dire que la
fortune désolant est d'à peu près les 70
millions de francs
moi de toute manière ça m'intéresse pas
j'ai mon mari qui s'occupent de moi et
je m'ennuie déjà blindé donc
la jeune garde c'est une famille mais
exceptionnellement n'ont pas tellement
on a beaucoup trop déçu mon mari
travaille comme un dingue pour essayer
de le maintenir sa voix là alors je vois
en carry ville cherche que toute
intervention des scores richard
bohringer bonsoir
refermons françois richard je vois que
le mcs et avec richard bohringer
comment ça va richard là bas ça va très
bien ce qui veut dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est que la semaine
dernière richard est venu il est venu
jusque là jusque là et il est parti
parce qu'effectivement il ne pouvait pas
attendre cette semaine ça va richard et
attend comment tu présentes feutrée qui
pouvait pas attendre j'ai attendu
jusqu'à 1h45 du matin
et il pouvait pas attendre
mais ça va ça va ça va
et claude makelele est avec vous richard
vous a vu aux amis bon vous êtes
sénégalais on vous a mis avec un
congolais on essaye de de faire des
pères dans cette émission j'espère que
ces réussites dont on est bien tout va
très bien ça va très bien agréable oui
et rappelle la période thierry ta vie tu
es en première invitée aux attentes
watts en jalles
toi tu dois être méfier parce que
j'arrive tedjar la dernière fois j'étais
prévenue là là je vais faire le tour
j'arrive leur entrée dans ce jeu c'est
qu'on est bouddhiste maintenant que la
semaine dernière je ne savais pas il
fallait me prévient
richard t'en fais pas on termine madame
était le prochain client arbitres m
on va s'occuper de son chakra
ocarina princesse
bon et l'a donc vous vous êtes évader un
petit peu de cet univers à travers la
peinture et la sculpture faut pas
oublier aussi que j'étais gravement
malade sa c'est sony vous avez je ne
vais pas parler hein je n'avais pas
parlé c'est pourtant très importante et
discret là dessus pour beaucoup de
personnes qui souffrent peut-être
maintenant et qui en sont peut-être dans
les hôpitaux et qui sont à deux doigts
de la mort comme moi je l'étais et je
crois que ça ça c'est une souffrance que
je ne souhaite à personne ne souhaite à
personne de passer dans tous ces moments
où j'ai su que j'allais mourir à 27 ans
vous annonce vous n'avez plus de deux
ans de vie c'est comme si on vous lancer
dans un avion avec un parachute et que
vous n'avez pas de parachute à vous
tomber en chute libre et vous vous
demandez où est ce que je tombe puisque
je tombe puis tout d'un coup c'est une
force de volonté de dire je reprends toi
main et je remonte les marchés ce que
disait ce que disait christophe tout à
l'heure au sujet de sophie des marais
c'est quand on a frôlé la mort on
apprécie plus la vie ça vous fait quoi
diane de france de voir qu'aujourd'hui
les châteaux servent à tourner la star
academy ou des crimes d'un qu
elle va les basses et une et c'est une
époque qui était voulu effectuer
et oui vous en prenez votre parti oui et
ça vous fait quoi de voir que stéphanie
de monaco épouse un acrobate portugais
par exemple ça c'est sympa c'est son
problème mais ça vous choque vous êtes
choqués parce que vous vous avez tous un
mur tender qu'est ce que c'est le côté
acrobates ou portugais c'est à dire que
maintenant le gouvernement portugais a
démenti c'est pour te dire à quel point
c'est grave wen en portugais dit qu'ils
n'étaient pas portugais oui c'est moi en
quoi par exemple de voir que jérôme
leroy était obligé de jouer à guingamp
de ses tournées et que le futur roi
d'italie épouser une roturière ça vous
fait quoi on va ça fait bizarre comme
quand même et les princes de l'usap
jacques baudoin
vient alors le bouquin s'appelle jeanne
de france princesse rebelle et on va
voir si vous êtes une vraie rebelle
interview rebelles
[Musique]
sérieux robel laurent diane de france
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit des gros
mots ah oui
j'avais déjà dit des gros mots genre
quoi zut des trucs comme ça non fichtre
bleu ou fichtre bleus non non
saperlipopette
ah oui à sa place j'aime de france
est-ce que vous avez déjà porté un jean
voir si vous êtes trop belle oui est-ce
que vous avez déjà fêter le 14 juillet
pas souvent parler c'est arrivé quand
même nous qui l'avons
d'orléans mais alors est-ce que vous
êtes déjà fait pire c'est le nombril
budget par
robert
boulin
aurait des années des années bravo bien
mais qu'est ce que est ce que vous avez
déjà fait l'amour sans désir de procréer
non maintenant six enfants ouais c ela
fait l'amour six fois je crois que le
compte est bon les lettres
est-ce que vous avez déjà mis des coudes
sur la table dès l'âge et vous avez-vous
oui oui la rebelle rebelles et quand
vous mangez nacarat jna est-ce que vous
avez déjà embrassé une personne de votre
sexe non cydia non non non est-ce que
vous avez déjà embrassé votre sexe
[Musique]
2 quand elle est imitée géant messieurs
là
non
et
[Musique]
maintenant voici les changer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
charmant âgées
les charbons soir
alors mesdames messieurs je crois je
sans toi tu le dit richard danger
richard bohringer qui pour être sûr
d'être là ce soir à baden
passé la semaine même si c'est à la
sortie rien je reviens 10,1 je te dis
que ça fait rien de rien et tout ce qui
dira c'est toi qui ment
c'est clair et ben moi je la tabac si tu
me touches je monte en jeu la fracasse
taille de
la république
était un pavé de la manière dont tout le
présente quand même l'impression qu'il
est arrivé en haut des marches et puis
tu sais barré tu l'as fait attendre
trois plombes quand même
c'est pas vrai que j'étais pressé mais à
1h45 du matin
on a un agacement dit mon pote attendait
pendant 30 ans et on se casse
non richard tu as eu raison alors à ta
place j'aurais fait pareil j'en suis sûr
ce qui m'a pas empêché de regarder
l'émission
comment comment tu t'es trouver
bien alors est bien moins cher tu
connais diane de france mais je j'ai eu
l'occasion de dans la loge de l est très
cool tu vas très cool mon esprit ouais
elle fait l'accueil pour faire des
enfants n'a pas vraiment honteuse c'est
pas normal ça mais très sympa quote oui
très sympa bien en fin de contrat bien
comptés si elle fait vraiment l'amour
que pour faire des enfants elle a fait
que six fois on est tous les
publics des congés payés en reste quand
même si
rappelez vous gêner les statistiques
richard oui c'est beau une ville la nuit
tu veux revenir tu veux revenir
ces navettes a qu'à arrêter le la nuit
mais donne lui maintenant il est bon on
donne la carte au bon client je donnerai
la fin on écoute pour l'instant nous
écoute en plein on a perdu dont je suis
ensemble est une bande de jeunes
c'est beau une ville la nuit
disait
best-seller 1,5 million d'exemplaires ça
fait beaucoup d'argent ça quand même il
est où le pognon oui l'argent voilà
c'est pas jean claude gobé tu la
gelée but non mais ça fait du blé est à
un million deux exemplaires et pas que
j'ai fréquentés on avait dès samedi soir
américains parce que les américains
c'est samedi où on se met la cuite voilà
qu'avec il ya longtemps un
ouais ouais ouais donc c'est beau une
ville la nuit 1,2 million d'exemplaires
ensuite une émission de radio sur europe
2 pendant sept ans et aujourd'hui c'est
un spectacle et un cd ouais voilà
c'était plein ce soir il ya eu deux
heures de concert voilà donc à une heure
de rappel c'est en 2h plus leur donnera
plus lors de rappel ce qui fait 3
secondes bien là comptent bien que je
sois resté longtemps s'il fait pas
d'erreur je sais pas me chauffe pas moi
je n'ai pas d'éclater l'islam est
prévenu mais ça va partir l'esprit
tranquille c'est moi le fils et
on regarde le cauchemar semble
varier tour
hier soir qui balance un coup de boule
rose derrière grenoble
qui avait fait des vagues gueule
il ya de la musique américaine
j'ai vu un cow boy qui attendait son
tour à texaco
desautels à 100 car bâle
avec des façades comme les cartes
postales en louisiane mendy dans la
lumière
mettre dans la lumière à venir
toi et tous les boxeurs du monde
faut savoir que la souffrance le temps
un gros paquet souffrance boxeur
terrassiers mineurs animal humain
pourtant
ceyrac de change
il faut te piquer ta couronne voilà et
s'est engagé le groupe aventure
c'est beau une ville la nuit
alors ce qu'on vient d'entendre c'est
dans ce même dit donc une chanson dédiée
à votre ami le boxeur mendy un régal
terminer champion du monde et voilà
auxerre sénégalais voilà 14 ans 15 ans
de boxe 15 ans de route ensemble à lui
parler de l'afrique avant les combats
voilà c'est une belle histoire alors ce
spectacle que vous venez de voir pouvez
le voir au théâtre le méry place clichy
à 20 heures du mercredi au samedi donc
voilà ça a l'air très très bien j'ai
braz les gens sont heureux ouais donc
c'est mission accomplie voilà ça passe
ça passe comme quoi on peut être acteur
écrivain chanteur quand original ans non
mais c'est vrai quand on a du talent
cuisinier
attachante réfléchir pour savoir si
c'est une vanne ce que tu viens de faire
faire ce que je vois ce que je suis un
dollar
richard houis préparer un troisième
roman maintenant ouais une espèce de
voyage comme s'attend à un taux de 2
quête de soi vous dites on y trouvera
les raisons profondes qui me pousse à
voyager au risque de déstructurer ma
famille mais en même temps un escalier
astrid pour tous
je pense que c'est une grande dame
qu'elle sait qu'il faut que je
il faut que je vole avec le vent ouais
facile
la richesse
de vos ventes richard richard si tu veux
lui remettre une je la protège je te
promets pourquoi il se pencherait sur r
oui c'est ce qu'il a dit
là tu le dis
alors c'est injuste excellent diane est
une fille formidable malgré tout malgré
tout qui me fait le ménage ton fait une
autre clause tu bouges un orteil je
t'explose
tient donc à street dont sérieux là
quand même c'est ça va
ça va
casting vannes
c'est pas une bonne c'est juste je te
mets juste au parfum que ça va
bien non mais c'est vrai vous dit
richard vous avez 61 ans 62 pas vous les
faites pas plus fait encore 33 tiens ça
presse oui
salut fils oui je peux pas m'arrêter
même dormir j'ai du mal faut que je
bouffe du bitume et vous fait cinq cent
mille kilomètres par an quand ouais
ouais je fais en tous les cas de 100000
oui étant guézel comment tout
est ce que tu te retrouves c'est plus
économique seuls et ils polluent ah ça
c'est vrai a pas que lui ban a d'autres
mais cela tranquille la princesse
la touche pas la princesse est un
message de wall street pour dire richard
tu rentres
elle avait déjà envoyé
les chars
vous êtes tombé amoureux de l'afrique à
25 ans 1 et puis vous avez fait ce film
que j'adore ça je vais en parler ça
super film dans le film de giraudeau oui
car c'est ce qui fait des caprices du
feu voilà qui est un film extraordinaire
absolument inconnu par rapport à ce que
ça représente c'est vrai ah c'est un
film magnifique magnifique et là
vous commencez à vous sentir de plus en
plus attirés par l'afrique et vous
demandé il ya un an la nationalité
sénégalaise devrait même si c'est
toujours pas des papiers au nom mais les
papiers jaurès et à la sénégalaise il va
faire ça c'est pas l'heure c'est pas
l'heure ça fait quand même un nom un 17e
n'ont apparemment c'est aussi dur pour
un français d'avoir des papiers sénégal
ics pour le sénégalais n'ont maintenant
c'est plus dur pour un sénégalais
d'avoir des pépins français d'accord
bien
et charbon âgées pour voir si malgré
l'absence de papiers vous êtes vraiment
sénégalais on va faire une interview
franco sénégalaise
[Musique]
richard bohringer pendant la coupe du
monde lors du match france sénégal vous
étiez pour qui
au sénégal est là il est sénégalais
quelles réactions avez vous quand la
france expulse des ressortissants
sénégalais beaucoup de chagrin et je me
sens humilié moi même et quand le
sénégal excuses des ressortissants
français
j'aimerais savoir ce qu'ils ont fait
aussi
[Musique]
on sait que dans ce sens là c'est on
n'expulse pas du sénégal comme ça non
plus donc
comme je ne sais rien de ses hommes je
rajouterais enquête guerre vous battrez
pour quel pays la france où sénégal je
me battrai je me battrai dans un an je
me battrai je me battrai pas contre le
sénégal et je me battrai pas contre la
france non vous ferez quoi alors des
heures tu verras en prison un déserteur
attendu par les couilles mais je me
battrai pas contre la france et je me
battrai pas contre le sénégal mais c'est
quoi un m'as fait à hama fait ouais pour
voir s'il est vraiment sénégalais même
si ces humbles à nos meilleures notes
soit c'est pour toi centre c'est pour
tout ça mais c'est d'accuser pour moi
vasic l armée au départ qu est cette
fois il faut du mit il faut
des oignons combien d'oignons peut faire
à ma fait avec du poisson fumé du passé
de la balade du poulet
du chouchou hamel choix africain c'est
un choix des mots est ce que ça prend
tout chaud
qu'est-ce qui lé monde soit africain il
y aura beaucoup 1 1 ouais savoir que
malgré les très belles affiches aller en
vacances
au sénégal
faut savoir quand même qu'il ya eu la
famine au sénégal l'année dernière et
que quand on parle des petits choux
y aurait besoin de petits choux là bas
beaucoup moins
à
lancer un petit message si vous voyez un
groupe qui s'appelle jusqu'à quand
jusqu'à quand jusqu'à quand c'est un
groupe de l'océan indien c'est un groupe
de sega c'est le plus grand leader de
ces gars qui s'appelle pounia jusqu'à
quand allez si vous voyez des amis ou
dans la france parce qu'il va venir
faire quelques concerts j'ai pas les
dates syriennes jusqu'à quand
je m'excuse au maire
m
c'est joli c'est joli et peaufine j'dis
14 ouais ouais
les charges sont aventure c'est beau une
indigente tout dire on sait tous les
soirs lors le vent fort mais bourré spi
c'est pas ma valeur
oui messieurs
tous sa marotte
le demi
quand même la nuit
rappelé me mo et maintenant
oh
[Musique]
mon don d'organes
enfin si claude makelele
[Musique]
jonakait mesdames messieurs bonsoir
heureux de vous avoir avec nous avant de
parler claude de vos exploits sportifs
au real de madrid et puis maintenant à
chelsea on va rester sur l'afrique
justement car vous avez décidé de
soutenir la campagne d'amnesty
international pour la signature d'un
traité international sur le commerce des
armes 1 alors on va prendre les choses
de 0,2 0,8 avec la clé du match a même
pas commencé
c'était fera en lisant
bien alors
si makelele en même temps 2 0 tout de
suite ses batteries
c'est pouvait éviter de vous disputer
non alors on va pas discuter je les
observe cedac
des six observations
[Musique]
tellement
bien alors clos donc 7 mai à kinshasa au
congo ex zaïre
il ya 30 ans et vous avez quitté le
zaïre à l'âge de 4 ans pour rejoindre
votre père en france votre père avait
quitté l'afrique pour aller en europe il
avait fui le régime de mobutu exact
pourquoi il avait fui le régime de
mobutu vrai qu'à l'époque
le président ne laisser aucun joueur
aller jouer à l'étranger oui mon père et
les joueurs d'alain donc vous êtes
obligés de se sauver entre guillemets et
c'est ce qu'a fait mon père et beaucoup
de joueurs
non la suit après alors votre père
quitte l'afrique quitte le congo enfin
le zaïre
justement à cause de mobutu et vous vous
avez rencontré mobutu quelques années
plus tard sans problème non non non
c'est vrai que ça s'est passé
j'ai commencé un jouer en pro 1 en
europe du plus beau jeu ramener tous les
ans dans mon pays est bon il a voulu me
rencontrer il avait compris la démarche
que mon père avait fait et puis moi
le fait que bon j'ai joué en europe ça
fait que
c'était un entre guillemets pour lui un
plaisir qu'un jeune africain congolais
réussissant n'ont pas pu donc il a dit
vous avez beaucoup aux buttes ou non oui
vous souvenez de l'anniversaire de
dikembe mutombo gt1 une soirée qui avait
organisé par mobutu et on était tous les
deux lamas ouais ouais donc ils nous ont
offert les canaux voilà non ce que je
peux dire parce que si vous en parlez je
peux en parler
oui bien sûr maintenant c'est mobutu qui
reçoit qui reçoit un certain nombre de
sportifs de haut niveau des sportifs
congolais et qui leur montre des spas
des espèces de soucoupe comme ça ou de
plats dans lesquelles il y avait des
diamants c'est sain c'est simple et vous
dis servez vous voilà
j'étais jeune à l'époque c'est vrai que
j'avais je ne sais pas trop ouais t'as
pas osé de la pause elles n'ont pas
déposé nombreux n'abrite elle a pris un
peu comme jouer un petit peu
plus ou moins que giscard
et qu'on les proportions comme demande
bristow
la bouffe
non c'est vrai dans le code vous
grandissez en france epinay sous sénart
et vous jouez au foot à
boussy-saint-antoine mais vous gardez
effectivement le contact avec le zaïre
enfin le congo où vous retourner chaque
été alors votre région est épargné par
les conflits régionaux mais votre
famille aurait pu être victime des
horreurs qui ont ensanglanté votre votre
pays et vous avez pris conscience en
fait de ce qui se passait réellement un
jour quand une femme réfugiée politique
vous raconte que en fait ce qui s'est
passé au zaïre au congo donc c'est un
petit peu comparable aux atrocités
commises au rwanda mais c'est vrai que
je me suis plus intéressé en allant dans
mon pays est bon j'ai vu des choses
atroces 4 c'est cette femme la main
ouais on arrête le massacre de torture
de deux petites filles violet on va
complètement ouvert les yeux on avait
plus que ça encore et c'est vrai que
j'étais impressionné c'est une tristesse
et puis bon j'ai j'ai décidé de
l'intégrer dans son combat mais c'est ça
c'est à dire que vous trouvez qu'on n'en
parle pas assez donc vous avez décidé de
vous engager pour la première fois de
votre vie c'est courageux auprès de
liliane thuram et d' amnistie pour
dénoncer et militer pour le contrôle
international des armes dans ce que vous
souhaiter vivement c'est la signature
d'un traité international et c'est ça
dont il ya une démarche qui est fait
donc on essaie de mobiliser
peu près tout le monde pour pouvoir
essayer de mettre un terme au moins
sensibilisé les gens importants que tu
puisse intervenir montrez votre t-shirt
là
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
vour aider ce mouvement il ya n'en sera
que ben le plus important sensibiliser
les gens et puis ben si la plupart des
gens peuvent intégrer un au mouvement
qu'on aurait 90 refaire ça a énormément
sensibiliser les gens au dessus pour
intervenir il ya un site internet qui à
mon avis va s'inscrire en bas de l'écran
c'est ce qui se passe d'habitude dans
ces cas-là problème je peux voilà
a très bien c'est
vrai en france est aussi l'un des
marchands d'armes
alors connais quelques-uns ont pignon
sur rue jean pignon sur vous et bien
alors ben écoute et à part ça tout le
monde connaît votre carrière de
footballeur nantes d'abord vous avez
tout appris ensuite l'om où ça a pris le
jeu individualiste et la salle ambiance
je crois qu'on peut dire que l'ol oui
vous n'avez pas été retenu pour la coupe
du monde 98 comme quelques années plus
tard vous ne serez pas retenu pour
l'euro 2000 en revanche en 2002 vous
étiez là vous étiez en corée avec la
chambre au dessus de la boîte de nuit
avec l'ascenseur
direct j'ai connu ça sympa très bien
c'était le premier match mais pour
rigoler non mais je n'étais pas bon je
crois que on était
un hôtel à côté ça on avait accès ont un
accès assez facilement à l'ambiance
qu'elle veut dans un autre voilà vous
avez rien foutu vous avez perdu la coupe
du monde enfin vous en veux pas non plus
alors ensuite
on était déçu quand même mais pas eux
sont éclatés à présent
chambre
biens détruits dans beauté beauté
vient ensuite le celta vigo et là vous
connaissez un certain succès le club
marche bien
votre
talent vous attire un certain nombre de
propositions financièrement astronomique
pour un transfert des pleins pleins de
proposition et vous choisissez de le
real de madrid le club évidemment il ya
les zidane figo raul ronaldo beckham il
l'a alors le problème est une espèce de
truc bras de fer tu connais l'histoire
une espèce de bras de fer contre les
dirigeants du real parce que tous les
gens que je viens de citer là il était
payé quatre ou cinq fois plus que vous
et vous dites y'a pas de raisons je dois
pas de sens je suis là il a un bep de
comptabilité
il connaît les chiffres il voit bien
qu'il est moins bien payés
l'effet que
j'avais fait cette démarche dans la
mesure où la paume années que je suis
arrivé j'avais eu une discussion avec le
président donc qu'ils m'avaient tu
m'avais promis la deuxième année qui
aurait une autorisation des annonces à
l'air et c'est surtout pas passer
démarche là que je me suis senti un peu
si oui il tâte un petit pont salariale
il est parti à chelsea et voilà les cinq
cent mille vols par semaine
l'argent de poche rien que pour les
filles et les gars n'ont jusqu'à des
jeunes très très bien c'est bien ça fait
combien en porsche non mais me combe pas
encore fait il quand on ferrari modena
quadrio décante pas encore ça y est la
malheureuse est de passer de l'autre
côté vous êtes une grande star du
football européen chelsea tout va bien
voilà etc et pourtant et je trouve ça
très touchant votre meilleur souvenir
c'est votre premier titre de champion de
france avec nantes
oui c'est vrai enfin c'est là où
vraiment j'ai vraiment pris du plaisir
j'ai je connais un entraîneur avant moi
qui m'a qui m'a tout appris voilà ça
reste le meilleur moment de votre vie à
la naissance de sa fille quand même quel
plus bel événement qu'est c'est vrai
qu'il a une fille
trop tard ça motive
parce qu'avoir du sage ou ballon on m'a
prise en étau la mecque est cool ont
versé bâton tactique et qui de barbares
ici toi avant l'heure
alors que le mcee
j'appelle chez moi à peine chez lui elle
c'est fort là il est fort mais là je
fais parce que je trouvais trop de
chance ce soir elle rentre vite on paye
ouest et y allez laurent claude makelele
désormais un cadre on peut dire de
l'équipe de france et c'est normal on va
vous faire une interview les yeux dans
les bleus
[Musique]
comme makelele est il vrai est il vrai
que claude makelele aurait dû jouer en
équipe de france depuis bien longtemps
oui oui est il vrai que l'ambiance en
équipe de france est finalement assez
chiante non
est il vrai que zidane ne perd pas ses
cheveux mais qui les donne à des enfants
qui n'ont pas
l'intention pas bête hein je préfère les
gens me voient bien que tu es méchant
j'ai recommencé à vous avez dix morts
claude makelele est il vrai que lilian
thuram passe pour un intellectuel parce
qu'ils y l'équipe avec des petites
lunettes non non et il est vrai qu
emmanuel petit ne veut plus jouer en
équipe de france depuis que l'équipe de
france ne veut plus jouer avec lui
non est il vrai que franck leboeuf est
parti au qatar pour pu voir sa femme à
la télé
non
non parce qu'il a la télé au qatar et
donc ça marche pas et tu devrais que
thierry henry est surnommé d'anaconda à
cause de la taille de sa à cet
objet dressage
par celle d'anvers en fait
claude nom
sylvain petit but non
non match est pas normal c'est pas comme
twilight choisir avant tout à fait mis
en danger
là
et maintenant mesdames messieurs je vais
laisser diane de france partira comme
bruxelles
5 lambert et l éther pipi je crois qu'on
peut le dire arrivent au meilleur ça
arrive aux meilleurs il va revenir alors
en attendant passé à tout le monde s'en
mêle
[Musique]
alors tout le monde s'en mêle pourquoi
béatrice dalle fume dans votre émission
me demande énormément de mails bah
écoutez je suis pas moi elle est libre
de se suicider non elle fume temps
qu'elle veut moi ça ne me dérange pas
à part ça moi je suis un petit peu
inquiet quand même de voir autant de
gens réclament et du flicage c'est
jamais bon quand les gens voient des
mers 20 faut lui interdire de fumer je
trouve que le flicage réclamé par la
population c'est pas un truc que je
trouve très bien
alors beaucoup de mails de
téléspectateurs qui regardent comme on
en parle en noir et blanc à cause du
verre un mail de stephan vallet de dijon
vent ford fiesta tdi abel reis 4000km
7800 euros hier à l'aube à tdi
c'est bien pour que
bruno d'arcangelo de tâches
alors on a pris une leçon là les bons
plans sont n'est pas aussi écoute mais
toi tu sais bruno d'arcangelo de
villejuif la capitale du surinam mon
cher thierry et paramaribo et non pas
paname haribo ça veut rien dire en plus
pas de marques à l'antenne arrière déjà
dit que c'était une connerie là je suis
désolé voilà je me suis planté
la capitale de la tasmanie aux barthes
un mec de céline sujet de céline dion
pourquoi n'inviter vous jamais céline
dion bas parce que la perche 1 qu'elle
est venue de thaler
madrid paris me demande de lui indiquer
un bon club échangiste chez moi non à la
réserve a
été son anniversaire avec son chéri oui
je lui conseille plutôt un dîner aux
chandelles et
le forum tnp est ouvert sur le site
france2 pour parler de l'émission après
l'émission y'a pas de problème on se
retrouve tous après son incident
concernant l'accès à ça tombe
bien c'est rené théobald tu m'as envoyé
une capture d'écran ça c'est
l'ex-premier regarde ce qu'il va envoyer
c'est magnifique c'est une capture
d'écran fait par rené théobald voilà
acéré que j'en viens même si c'est bon
il ya m6 il ya mathieu ricard il se voit
là alors vous aussi si vous réalisez de
belles captures d'écran vous me les
envoyer et je les montrerai à l'antenne
le samedi soir tout ça formidable en
abyme de l'emi un bien bonne idée un
mail qui sert de légende finalement à
cette photo est ce que matthieu ricard
serait devenu ce qu'il est devenu s'il
avait eu la vie de m6 jean gabin l'a
sûrement nombre
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant
tout ça
le pas
voici que françois junior
[Musique]
jo
je
[Musique]
voilà claude françois junior avec
aurélie joy elisa heureux de vous
connaître ce qui m'étonne des années
qu'est-ce qu'on s'emmerde à faire cette
émission on pense à ta femme ah oui
c'est vrai ça va t'aider
bien à lui courrèges courage tiens donc
et ici tous les quatre pour la comédie
musicale belles belles belles à
l'olympia du 21 novembre 18 janvier et
puis en tournée à partir de février dans
toute la france voilà donc dont claude
ici présents et le coproducteur avec
notre ami qui était aussi l'ami de joey
starr gérard louvin
alors c'est un spectacle est écrit par
daniel moyne et jean pierre bourtayre la
chorégraphie et de reda alors il faut
dire un petit mot du spectacle c'est pas
il n'y a pas un sosie de cloclo avec une
perruque à un costume à paillettes c'est
l'histoire de trois jeunes filles vous 3
mes enfants qui participent à un
concours de chant demi finales et donc
on suit comme ça leur entraînement et
puis là leur vie intime on suit aussi
leur dîner intime voilà le tout autour
de 23 succès de claude françois voilà
alors l'album sort le 20 octobre et le
premier single c
j'attends
[Musique]
à
thierry rolando est riche l'équipe vient
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'attendrai par les filles cet extrait
de la comédie musicale
belles belles belles
comédies musicales l'olympia à partir du
21 novembre
alors effectivement donc comme je les
dis c'est pas comme ça un sosie de
cloclo et des musicales comme les deux
d'avoir cep à la vigne ou de mains en
l'air sur scène puis c'est vraiment une
comédie musicale au sens anglo saxon du
terme certes il ya 50 ans en octobre et
10 50 concerts de musique des autres 50%
c'est quoi non sans une mise aux
élections sans qu'il y ait dans le passé
il n'y a pas non vraiment aux dates où
il n'y a pas un il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas trois tubes comme on peut
l'attendre
les trois autres 50 50 50 vous êtes à
trois sur le coup 53 quand même est-ce
que vous avez déjà vu une comédie
musicale il ya vingt-trois tubes we will
à des deux boules
mamma mia oui
ça va marcher ça va cartonner
c'est surprenant c'est mauvais ça
n'existe pas à part ma mamie à londres
c'est un va arriver en france avec un
genre complètement nouveau elles
arrivent les derniers dans la course on
arrive du 21 novembre et je suis ravi
parce qu'on va vraiment avoir on va
apporter une bouffée d'oxygène aux gens
qu'ils énormément
je tombe
[Musique]
elle est belle
est-ce que
[Musique]
maintenant laurent j'ai besoin de toi et
intérêts au mieux connaître nos jeunes
amis aurélie
bonsoir thierry henry donc vous êtes la
plus connue des trois en fait parce que
vous avez fait la star ac de tirs la
star ac 2 pour ceux qui suivent pas
c'est celle de nolwenn et des mâts et
donc vous êtes en main je crois qu'on
peut le dire vous êtes avec alexandre ne
vais pas me marier non c'est juste pour
la baisse des loyers
pas de sentiments ça ils ont été très
clairs là dessus beaucoup de sentiments
mais un mariage c'est pas forcément
évident il est comme alexandre en herbe
vous me le dit fier
de pain vous inscrire
certes le plan
maintenant passer à la deuxième candidat
alors quelle est la couleur pour attirer
la commande d'un navire va arriver
quelqu'un sait que ce soit dans un boîte
de nuit un plateau de télévision n'est
ni pareil hakim fais toi je parle date
qui nous rejetons prix pas de nouvelles
c'est du bidon
bien
oui c'est bien ça l'a bien fait la
peinture
je veux colorier de
cette
rencontre est bien à 17 ans travaillent
ils ont fait notre boulot un
bon job était alors qu'une interruption
je comprends pas pourquoi vous a été
refusée la star ac quand vous savez ça
c'est tout non non c'était rencontré
l'année dernière au casting final en
fait on était fin j'étais mais parmi les
50 derniers puis voit la main le défunt
dans le château
d'accord vous êtes là maintenant on en
mange personal donc après ça vous décidé
de prendre une année sabbatique 1
à paris là où je suis assez fou rire oui
j'ai pas aimé ça mais si vous disiez ce
voyage
sabbatique pour essayer de passer des
castings de chant etc ans et cette année
donc en février dernier j'ai appris hier
un casting musical j'étais pas du tout
enfin je savais que ça parlait de claude
françois enfin il y avait claude
françois dans l'histoire mais je savais
pas du tout ce que ça allait être et
voilà je me suis présenté puis j'aime
beaucoup pense à ta femme mordelles
le rheu choisi toi bon 500 francs
moi je suis ravi non
je suis ravi qu'elle que choisir ça
prouve que les personnes qui l'ont
choisi ont du goût et du talent mais
joli c'est vrai et puis moi très
contemporaine moyens avec moi je suis
pas sur elle tout
c'est le cas la veste marron elle
pourra pas
être réel
j'accroche pas
conserver ma kifissia
[Musique]
bien alors vous êtes bac bravo
without à la caisse
quand vous chantez toutes les trois vous
appelez les filles d'original c'est pas
trop compliqué pour son souvenir non
répondait je me dis les gars on nous
appelle comme ça donc ils ont gardé
20g originale soit 87 ans était bien
voilà je suis bonne idée parce que
j'essayais l'autre idée nous auriez
trouvé drôle de fille derrière
l'attendait on a remué pendant deux ans
200 dinars événement la vie elle est là
et bien là
mes trois filles peut-être doublé
peut-être l'indication niveau du chiffre
c'est pas pour éviter le nom mais sans
aller jusqu'à trente neuf personnes sur
scène belge kbc celle là les belles
belles belles derrière ces des tons
qu'il m'accorde
alors connais les productions comme les
framboisiers de mettre les bonnes salles
dessus
pas de fond de barquettes les meubles
alors vous feriez quoi les filles si
vous aviez un marteau
je donnerai la nuit je mettrai tout mon
coeur j'espère que vous mangez pas trop
il vous avez pas plus d'appelés dit qu
un barracuda
vadim et des pièces
pdc qui va mal aimé
l'aîné
les gens reconnaissent
je me montrais mes en chercher
demjanjuk
est pourquoi c'est toutefois caché au
fond de moi
écouter autrement
dit est-ce que il pleure votre téléphone
alors que donc si gérer le patrimoine
laissé par votre père claude françois en
1993 avait réouvert la maison de 10,2
peu de françois qui s'appelle les des
disques flèche après avoir entendu un
remix techno
de des magnolias il ya un raccourci mais
c'est sans nom je vous ai dit en 93 que
j'avais deux enfants et que je ne ferai
pas de carrière à la télévision
je me suis rendu compte que mon père
m'avait décidé d un outil de travail un
patrimoine débouchés commencé petit à
petit on le voit là et au delà de ça je
me suis rendu compte que les gens
commencent à se permettre de pouvoir
retoucher son propre travail un moment
donné je me suis dit ça veut dire qu'il
ya plus d'une il n'y a plus aucun
respect il ya plus personne qui serre la
vis et ça devient un libre accès pour
tous noirs le problème en corée du sud
dans la maison de disques qui s'est
souvent des jeunes mais qui sont
responsables du fonds de catalogue donc
y mettiez photo à l'envers ils ont dû me
faire faire des remixes et ça devient à
la foire d'empoigné et donc voilà j'ai
juste réouvert entre guillemets la
boutique pour dire où on est là
maintenant si vous avez besoin de ça sur
200 se mêle à la photo vous pouvez juste
nous appeler et puis petit à petit on a
repris contact avec tout le monde et
puis ça va nous en bien alors donc vous
décidez effectivement à ce moment-là de
vous consacrer à la mémoire de votre
père s'ils se dopait toujours facile
avis finalement un nom c'est moi je vais
vous dire pourquoi je vous dis ça je te
vois j'ai déjeuné avec le fils du
général de gaulle c'est dur d'être fils
le vol se doit être dur d'être le fils
de claude françois c'est la nuit c'était
plus dur quand j'étais enfant qu après
et puis et puis définitivement ça n'a
cessé d'être compliqué le jour je suis
devenu moi même le père de mes enfants
ouais et que j'ai commencé à me réalisés
entre guillemets petit à petit
professionnellement que je fais de la
production de jeunes artistes voilà donc
j'ai trouvé mon 1 entre guillemets ma
voix et je m'éclate dans mon boulot et
je vois mes enfants grandir et je suis
fils de mon père et j'en suis fier et
tout va bien mais ça veut dire qu'on va
faire une compile de fils du général de
gaulle non non c'est pas je vous ai
compris vive le québec est une question
à poser à claude quand même
bonsoir si vous aviez le choix de
revenir sur une heure une deuxième fois
est-ce que vous choisiriez
d'être le fils aîné de claude françois
[Musique]
oui oui parce que définitivement je suis
je suis très fier du travail accompli et
de la mémoire et de l'empreinte qui a
laissé mon père donc oui voilà
si on s'appelle pas bonne mais elle
est maintenant
latéral gauche luiz tout le monde joue
[Musique]
évidemment claude jouais pas évidemment
donc richard joue laurent joue
christophe les filles jouent mais pas
vous alors quel âge aurait claude
françois aujourd'hui s'il avait su
changer une ampoule
64 64 64 bravo
[Applaudissements]
j'ai joué en équipe et on va payer un
jeu me rectifié on va pas y rester deux
heures mais il ya évidemment qui sait
qu'ils savaient changer l'ampoulé qui il
a eu l'accident n'est pas survenue en
changeant une ampoule mais juste en
redressant inappliqué c'était un
perfectionniste et la vue d'une applique
de travers le rendre hystériques donc
voilà mais lorsqu'elle l'a dit
statistiquement il ya eu beaucoup moins
d'accidents
ménagers duales électricité à la suite
de son de son écrin
servia ça que je fais la lumière du
phare d'alexandrie pour claude françois
je
chante en moi non que fait la lumière
rapillard et fait vaciller les papillons
de nuit j'ai fait ça va si les papillons
de
l'outragé papillon de sa genèse brave
aurélie ont marqué un point
attention tout le monde se concentre
laurent baffie pour quelles activités
tout françois prenait-il le pseudo de
monsieur du moulin
pour livrer des messages dans la
résistance non
en plus du moulin avec son cortège de
team
[Rires]
composée par ailleurs nixon c'est pas du
tout françois dubout françois dumoulin
content que non quand on connaît un
petit peu l'étendue de ses activités
1 peut-être qu'on peut faire le
rapprochement de la nécessité d'avoir un
pseudo presse ont écrit à écrire oui
là-bas
à
votre
[Musique]
avis c'est pour faire des photos de
charme je conçois s'appelait monsieur du
moulin à cause du monde pour faire des
chantiers et que chacun aura compris les
petits mois après il fait 2 millions
d'exemplaires c'est un carton avec le
téléphone pleure chansons pour enfants
il définitivement mais voilà il abordait
il abandonne absolue un moment de l'été
les producteurs parfait alors maintenant
un vrai ou faux riches à on se console
en beau
patrick topaloff doit-il sa carrière à
claude françois ouais ouais ouais t'es
secrétaire et un champion aussi ouais
ouais qui a écrit les lundis au soleil
paraguay je crois que
c'est quand on est derrière les rideaux
qu'on travaille
au qu'elle aimait passer dans le ciel un
oiseau qui sape les coûts de la santé
oms a répondu
ouais 2 qui parlait que le françois dans
comme d'habitude sa femme maintenant
dans laquelle
je me lève et et je te bouscule tu ne
travailles pas jusque là rien d'anormal
sa maman
j'ai froid je relève mon col tout est
gris dehors mais qui sait cette
le n 10 un indice à lundi
ensuite elle a vécu avec julien clerc
fois les bravos des deux côtés
j'étais qui vante comme d'habitude est
une chanson consacrée je crois qu'on
peut le dire à la rupture avec france
gall pourquoi fallait-il venir
absolument dans la maison de claude pour
voir sa mère n'ont pas boire de vin non
il ya les oiseaux cris chants par les
oiseaux
le printemps
dans quelle chanson claude françois
explique qu il se masturbe devant des
revenus oui à 17 ans oui bravo c'est une
chanson j'ai vraiment solidaire vraiment
ravi c'est en fait un des chansons à 13
années de berger ensanglanté connaissait
pas le bout qui a gagné maintenant chez
les cadettes
quelques mois des champions vendeurs et
les gens c'est l'école
claude françois junior
[Musique]
m
c'est ak
on était en
mais si bien que chacun
[Musique]
j'ai un peu j'ai un bon soir ça va quoi
donc les filles et les garçons fois que
c'est assez facile ce soir d'animer
cette émission parce que d'un côté
bien alors bien belgique lors de votre
dernière visite ici c'était en 2001 tout
allait pour le mieux un fait qui innerve
extraordinaire je sais que serge july a
fumé trois tâches de cette herbe ils
étaient rétamer la une de libé était
très drôle d'ailleurs la semaine qui a
suivi et puis ensuite alors voilà la
galère voilà ses membres des partis
d'ici je sais pas ce qui s'est passé la
galère vous nous avez fait quatre pneus
moto racks
sequalum au thorax
ça
c'est un pont qui claque qu'on sait les
armes ça
peut-être un peu peut-être un peu un
autre fonction du nom
était un froid sas a foutu une ambiance
en l'air non mais c'est vrai
rassemblement base et continue alors
effectivement série noire je dirai pas
ce que la même année votre femme a un
grave accident de voiture se retrouve
dans le coma à l'hosto et après ça vous
avez plus du tout envie de faire
pierpoljak vous vous dites j'en ai ras
le bol
j'en ai ras-le-bol de chanter de faire
le chanteur je suis gavé du biz et des
babylon risque est une expression
extrêmement rasta gaver du biz et des
babylone riz et vous partez sur un
bateau puis à paul jacques avec votre
fils aîné
et votre femme vous l'avez laissée dans
la nièvre
non ma femme allait martiniquaise donc à
elle et en martinique a été retournée en
martinique vous avez abandonné la nièvre
pas vraiment non non si vous avez des
plantations là bas
c'est dommage avant de venir les beaux
chants
dont vous partez sur un bateau ouais et
là il va traîner est ce qui vous
changent les idées c'est d'abord le
bateau mais aussi la tempête force 9 que
vous essuyez quoi la cct ou c'est un
large de l'espagne en fait entre la le
la frontière entre l'espagne et le
portugal ouais un endroit qui s'appelle
la guardia grosses branlées de la morte
a dit grosse branlée de la mort où il
serait fort sonel ouais mais moi je suis
pas un
suis pas un super grand marin tu vas
vais pas passer ma vie non plus sur les
océans pour moi c'était là c'est la
première grosse voix douce avec son fils
non on était trois en fait pierpoljak
sont sur un bateau
voilà donc bizarre quoi la galère le
bateau la grosse blinde la mort et tout
est à ce moment là heureusement il ya
toujours des moments comme ça lors d'une
escale à la grenade vous écouter une
radio locale 1 vous écouter une radio
locale
du ragga et savoureux donne envie de
chanter
mais chanter et faire père paul jacques
ces deux trucs différents - puisque je
chante déjà de dépêcher toujours donc
voila quoi tu te demandes si envie
d'être coeur j'aimerais bien parler là
dessus mais vrai que je me lance en fait
l'annoncé ce soir bah ouais je vais
essayer à temps l'asie continue voilà de
retour à paris tu vas chez ta maison de
disques la barclays il t'aime bien mais
ils disent non vas pas de filets de
thunes quand même ils ont été assez dur
d'accord ouais il est un peu un peu
clébard chez barclay comme
tu le disais regarde je veux pas
commencer en arrivant là que tu fais
mais je n'en ai pas de taper sur mark
lee mais c'est vrai que bon ils n'ont
pas essayé par des mafieux russes à la
bassée jours
autant pour moi et donc tu décides de
produire toi même ton album à la
jamaïque l'album s'appelle steam
turballe
[Musique]
aidez moi
[Applaudissements]
m
si tu voyais david ans
lire tous les gens qui ne t'aime pas
compte des sourires
[Musique]
fabuleux merci
tu as pu les dreadlocks et tout ça non
plus là bas non tu dis je veux plus
faire croire aux gens que je suis rasta
alors que je suis pas rasta exact
cassette a fait un choc cette histoire
de motos wright mais c'est pas le pneu
moto racks vraiment qu'il ya aussi ils
prennent les acariens dans les
dreadlocks
non c'est pas bon la regardera toi on le
dit justement non mais c'est vrai
justement moi même si j'étais un peu
désespérée et tous les jours je les ai
coupés et où j'ai quand même regarder
dedans parce que j'essaie de prendre non
les miens hésiter bien qu il était clean
est ce que tu t'es dit finalement un
rasta blanc c'est pas possible donc
comme je suis blanc je vais arrêter tous
vos reste assez sage histoire oued blanc
sait déjà c'est déjà un non sens pour
être à star aux yeux à moi moi j'suis
pas et est aussi être as tu as et c'est
croire que à et laissez-la ci est dieu
ouais donc déjà si tu as passé de si tu
cites a passé de trucs là et que c'est
juste une histoire de tenues de bandits
l'apparence est de 1 et d'herbes et de
musique et de tout ça bon c'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui je veux dire comme
le tu vois j'ai pas 98% sûrement du new
way du truc mais quand est venu ici la
dernière fois tu nous as dit 4 as tu as
était croire à la divinité devant
l'empereur d'ethiopie à l'éjecter
d'acier heureusement que tu m'a pas
demandé mais toi est-ce que tu y crois
toi ouais ouais c'est vrai dis-moi
mauvaise nouvelle à l'apparent j'étais à
faire ça y est même si jean gabin qui
était la semaine dernière ouais c'est ce
qu'il a dit dans sa chanson je t'emmerde
je t'encule je te cuges des merdes tu
connais je connais il dit en parlant de
toi je sais pas chanter mais je sais
bien ratonner mais c'est dans la chanson
c'est vrai mais qu'est ce qu'il a dit en
direct et esquina vendait rasta quoi
ouais c'est vrai et c'est une surprise
non pas pour moi encore
moi jean gabin je le connais pas mais en
fait après la chanson tous à machin moi
un jour j'ai fait une chanson ce poisson
pané poisson pané est à vue qui est
question là web exactement voilà donc il
ya des gens qui connaissent ce soir j'ai
pas envie de faire un disque avec ça
c'était surtout pour que lui l'entendent
1 et
c'est pas pour parce que j'ai peur
qu'ils me tuent ou kim éclater tout
parce que c'est un gaillard tu vois
c'est pas ça c'est qu'après je me suis
penché un peu sur gg je suis tombé sur
des interviews de lui et tout ça et je
me suis un peu intéressé à son cas en
fait et en fait j'ai vu que c'est
déjà la chanson au départ quand je l'aï
entendu je les trouvais pas mal et après
quand j'ai vu son camp j'ai étudié son
cas on va dire j'ai vu que bon c'est un
gars bien quand ça va bien il est pas
mal quoi c'est un gars qui vaut le coup
entoure et galère galère quand même plus
vrai que bon nombre donc il faut il faut
le soutenir ouais mais nous on a soutenu
ici la semaine dernière il ya beaucoup
de manières pour nous parler de lui non
mais l'impression que j'ai là comme ça
c'est que tu reviens c'est la première
fois que tu fais une grosse télé de
c'est ça c'est exactement et tu te dis
est ce que ça me gave pas de faire ça
maintenant tu reviens tu dis est ce que
finalement j'ai envie comme ça tous les
deux ans tous les ans passés chez
ardisson chez fogiel chez match à abano
hélas souvent son site ici
si si je repars pour tu vas faire du
bateau est en fait ça sera pour ne plus
revenir parce que déjà j'ai créé une
fois en fait j'ai peut-être fait la
connerie tu pas continuer ce que j'ai
dans l'entreprise mois sur la scène je
suis plus à l'aise qui si par exemple tu
vois ou
peut-être que cette fesci finalement non
mais je vais me rodez regarde là c'est
la première mais je vais en faire ça va
déjà mieux qu'au début je dois garder
sous qui reviennent puisse remettre dans
diverses chauffer c'était une petite
dépression et j'ai l'impression qu'il va
pas bien tu vois il s'auto flagelle
alors c'est très bien c'est toujours ça
moi tu me connais pas rationnel
ouais elle est profonde elle un policier
[Musique]
non
hahaha
je
merci bien pensé avec nous inculture je
laisser partir un oui à temps il ya
sophie qu'apparemment
20 minutes va
qu'est ce qui t'a dit
je suis les dangers de l'alcool
et a dit non j'ai dit quelle salle
courage écrit qu'il partirait jamais ça
mettez vos personnages et élire moi je
vais tous les formidables il est super
ce n'est ce pas c'est la première fois
que je jouais pierpoljak sont très sympa
aussi puis un peu de jacques je le
connais bien et maintenant mais
messieurs j'appelle daniel héraud
[Musique]
d'allumer au bon soir amedi soir bonsoir
non mais moi j'ai un même qui dit vous
êtes sûr que vous n'êtes pas georges
moustaki n'ont à priori bon bah on peut
commencer alors comment ça va faire mal
aux formes et vous vous êtes obligés
d'avoir ce loup pour être daniel herrero
êtes tous bisexuels tout
donner pour les centièmes il doit y
avoir des exceptions des reconnaissances
alors vous publié chez plon mon cher
héros le dictionnaire amoureux du rugby
est ce que vous l'avez écrit dans votre
cabane en bois perché à 10 mètres de
haut sur l'arbre à la valette à l'entrée
de toulon là oui effectivement j'ai une
petite cabane vous montez non j'ai une
maison qui est plutôt sympathique et mis
à un grand arbre dedans et j'ai
construit là haut un bureau dans lequel
j'ai plaisir à écrire et à me reposer
ouais ouais alors daniel j'ai appris
qu'en dehors de vos activités d'écrivain
et de journaliste vous étiez consultant
auprès de grandes entreprises
pour parler ouvrez les guillemets de la
gestion des hommes dans la compétition
de l'esprit d'équipé du lien social
vous vouloir piquer du pognon à leur
compte en quoi ces grandes entreprises
ben effectivement je suis assez souvent
rémunérés après on peut discuter de la
hauteur mais dans les entreprises
il m'arrive d'intervenir sur le thème
effectivement du théâtre de l'équipe
l'entraîneur les cadres avec dédé des
costumes et des échecs et un moment ils
ont besoin de voir un type comme vous
qu'il est qui les ressources qu'il est
je pense que les cadres comme les comme
les commerciaux divers comme les humains
en général qui meublent de temps en
temps être dans la dynamique de
l'entreprise réfléchir sur ce que c'est
que le leader ou souvient que quelqu'un
qui entraîne les autres ouais un exemple
jamais fatigué je mets un coup de barre
ah ouais moi ça peut m'arriver on dirait
la dernière sont fatigués ouais
[Applaudissements]
je vous apporte du blé de données comme
ça des conférences dans des entreprises
je viens il décemment ma vie dans cette
activité ce n'est pas mon boulot à
l'exprimer jc oui vous fait d'autres
activités oui mais ça c'est bien je
trouve que c'est plutôt pas trop mal
mais ça me demandent de l'investissement
les bonnacois
mais je les ai toujours rouge et du
cézanne audio n'est qu'en apprenant ça
je me suis dit un mec avec une telle
tchatche il n'a pas besoin de moi pour
vendre son livre je crois que vous avez
trois minutes pour le faire tom kohn
bien parce que
c'est un ouvrage qui est une ballade
dans le monde du rugby qui n'est
finalement qu'un jeu quoi inventé par
les anglais déjà ce serait une énigme tu
vois mes lauriers tout le monde sait
aussi que c'est un esprit un univers
dans lequel il y à des hommes qui
s'affrontent déjà l'affrontement c'est
une réflexion il ya des haltes des
balades il il ya du jeu il ya des
champions il ya des stades il ya de la
culture sans doute il ya même de
l'histoire c'est sur deux siècles des
siècles d'aventuré humaine un jeu qui
derrière une compétition et peut être
une aventure un peu initiatique un
regard sur les humains sur le lien sur
le partage sur le solidaire sur le
courage peut-être enfin bon voilà c'est
une une immersion dans un monde qui est
un peu plus un sport sans doute le jeu
de rugby probablement est une un bout de
route peut être une école de vie sans
doute aussi un simple sport de
compétition et bientôt une grande
aventure mondiale chat on parle de
minutes un peu moins de deux minutes
continue daniel rey alors après le jeu
de rugby la ilaha illa des énigmes qui
sont fantasques matic et pas uniquement
dans l'esthétique des humains c'est le
seul jeu par exemple où il ya deux
marqué c'était intéressant après c'est
un jeu où pendant un tiers du temps tu
vois pas la balle et quand tu la vois
pas apparemment les hommes jouent et
quand il joue le public s'extasie de
voir des groupes qui s'affrontent c'est
ce qui se passe sous la mêlée voilà ça
c'est la belle énigme henry est il ici
parce que du lieu et du solide et d'être
un peu des flirts non il peut y avoir
désormais couvert d amour de vacances
avant de glisser un regard donc il a dit
ça serait
la bonne chose de faite ici pas ceux du
plus rude mais le rude et le doubs sont
jamais très éloignée achevé dans la soul
toi
laisse eux il y aurait une minute vas-y
daniel je pense que c'est dans cette
pratique aujourd'hui un regard un peu
poétique
humaniste peut-être un peu sociale sans
doute après il ya de la technique aussi
un ce dictionnaire qui est un peu
exhaustif raconte des histoires qui ont
trait à la mairie aux humains voilà
j'ose penser que c'est un petit bout de
route dans un microcosme sportif ou la
base humaine a un fondement voilà après
je peux répéter mais ça fait déjà trois
minutes mais on a une restreint de
seconde mais le récent de seconde alors
après je dirais bienvenus bienvenue pour
plonger un peu dans cet univers pour
essayer de te ressentir au centre de
cette aventure un il y à des chocs il y
à des chutes il ya du rude il ya du
partage il ya des mutations il ya des
vestiaires aussi rudoyant tu vois il ya
puis il ya des quête de gloire qui
viennent sympathique et puis de temps en
temps avoir l'envié d'aller caresser des
étoiles à nos valley et bien c'est
william borucki 17,6 voilà après
bienvenue collègues bienvenu s'il ya des
ratios voir grandir dans le nez d'heure
a fait aussi du bien l'adversaire
[Musique]
c'est chez plon
mais dis-moi qui
qu'est ce qu'il fout encore dans matinée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya le championnat du monde là qui
recommence de rugby on a des chances la
france
oui oui on objectivement oui et pas
uniquement avait le coeur sur l'analyse
des paramètres mais il y en a des
adversaires et qu'ils sont qui sont
pénibles certains même un peu supérieure
en face aux anglais en particulier ce
qui nous irrite mai mais que c'est un
constat objectif donc l'équipe de france
est allée potentiellement bel outsider
ouais elle devrait arriver en
demi-finale légitimement et après ça
risque de se gâter voilà dix mois la
porte tu n'aimes pas toi je dis la
vérité dernier d'aller à
la mairie c'est la porte où il un peu
maniaco-dépressive cela rigueur la
discipline dans la méthode mais moins
vrai aussi qu'ils soient un petit peu
dans la créativité je pense qu'il le
sera dans la conjoncture d'une coupe du
monde tu lui donner une chance ouais je
viendrais même plusieurs sincèrement
vous d'accord tu as avec nous on va
t'envoyer de coûts chez toi
et maintenant et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
m
wes ian gillan de deep purple
[Musique]
eloi deep purple mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ya un bonsoir bienvenue parmi
nous alors ce mot comme de ou auteur
s'est extrait du fameux album s'appelle
machine head qui a fait de deep purple
l'une des stars mondiales du rock'n'roll
alors smoke on the water ça veut dire
fumée sur l'eau est en fait cette fumée
sur l'eau c'est la fumée de l'incendié
du casino de montreux et l'os et l'eau
du lac léman ses parents un cancer ii de
frank zappa auquel vous assistiez à
l'époque la série j'ai écrit la chanson
immédiatement après ce qui s'est passé
c'est que nous étions au concert c'était
en novembre 71
faisait son dernier concert de la saison
quel autre montreux c'est une des
bâtisses en bois
je crois que c'était pendant le concert
de 2 a pas quelqu'un s'est pointé avec
un
avec un flingue à 11 flamand fait état
tout a brûlé tout a brûlé tout le monde
s'est taillé
les rolling stones avaient leurs camions
la sortie était prêt à partir le
lendemain alors il tout le monde s'est
retiré
à ses mille ans on a trouvé refuge dans
un pack que la vue de le casino flamber
et le vent a entraîné la fumée sur le
sur le lac et c'est de là qu'est venu le
titre de la chanson si ce nouveau bundle
walter la lie sur la chanson et dans le
même album qui s'appelle machine head il
y avait ça aussi highway star
deep purple highway star deep purple a
vendu plus de 20 millions d'albums dans
le monde à l'époque alors
avec l'aide des pinces et les inventeurs
du hard rock alors je croyais and que
vous aimez pas beaucoup le mot hard rock
ou le mot heavy métal ne s'est pas des
époux
on nous a traités de tous les noms enfin
progressif un que sais-je l'euro car il
mène alors non franchement peu importe
mais a dit m c'est pas une expression
qui me plaît beaucoup parce que et c'est
pas une expression bien musicale même si
ça vient du rock même s'il ya des
groupes rock qui s'appelle la vie
musicale un heavy metal c'est quand même
on est censé faire la musique que le
métal franchement ça donne une image
assez noir du rock et c'est pas ça on
n'est pas si noir que ça alors bon ce
qu'on a appelé les arbres coup le heavy
metal c'est une musique qui est né en
réaction un petit peu à la musique
planante au flower power et c'est sûr
qu'à un moment vous avez ressenti le
besoin avec vous vos amis de deep purple
le le besoin de revenir à quelque chose
de plus fondamental de plus violents de
plus rock'n'roll quoi
plus violents peut-être pas mais plus
puissant certainement l'idée c'est que
tout ce qu'ils étaient flamands parue à
tout ça c'était quelque chose
d'intéressant il y avait beaucoup de
noirs baudon de de vibrations et nous
quand on était gamins on écoute chez
l'us creysse la chapellerie détendre et
chats dépit et sont arrivés les fleurs
pas alors qu'ils étaient très sympas
quand vers d'autres ports il y avait un
peu plus tôt dans tout cela mais ce
qu'il fallait peut-être revenir à nos
racines un peu plus puissante des
clients de ça j'étais foule des fous de
moi rogers glover et j'étais un ami
l'avait
bien dit ce qu'il vient de dire sur
cette espèce de fragilité cavell la
musique flower
de d'être réactif sur le coup
heureusement ça nous a quand même sauvé
la grande endormissement musicale quoi
alors voilà aujourd'hui après 35 ans
dans une carrière émaillée de
séparations deep purple revient avec un
nouvel album qui s'appelle bananas alors
bananas en fait et on le voit sur la
pochette d'ailleurs si à cause d'un
indien qui portent des bananes sur son
vélo et vous dites que ces bananes là on
les voit jamais en europe parce que le
type de bananes en question est interdit
quoi c'est la commission européenne
interdit d'importer ses bananes là et
c'est très symbolique finalement vous
dites de l'idiot cratie qui gère le
monde aujourd'hui
accordé à l'époque c'est moi qui ai
effectivement appelé scène idiocracy
c'est moi qui ai inventé cette
expression à quelques secondes pourquoi
parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour tous
vient d'europe j'ai vécu un peu partout
en europe en allemagne en france un peu
partout et en france où dit vive la
différence au moins en français c'est
une expression que je voudrais juste
vous avez des tas la culture qui se
rejoignent mais là à l'autre bout du
monde les gens souffrent de ces
réglementations invraisemblable à
bruxelles mme a décidé que des bananes
doivent mesurer exactement trente
centimètres pas plus ni moins et je
mangeais excellente banane au milieu de
la semaine dernière qui était délicieuse
mais il y avait que deux bouchers à
faire mais où est le problème
g
nous
mais
[Musique]
on écouterait à l'entente car c'est ma
vie c'est tellement com com du pink
floyd mais ces normes parce que si tu
madrid c'est toujours c'est toujours
aussi bien c'est toujours aussi un c'est
toujours aussi ça sert à rien et huawei
toujours aussi élégant ça s'appelle
animée s'est extrait de bastia et c'est
une guitare magnifique leçon de cette
guitare
d
écoutez
bardot ça me fait plaisir
elle nous rappelle à
la grèce allait bien elle a donc acheté
l'album pitié alors qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de revenir après toutes ces
années yann
j'en avais passé que quelques années
en dehors du groupe peut-être trois ans
maximum et puis j'avais pas c'est quoi
des années merveilleuses avec deep
purple et puis j'ai vu qu'il avait rien
d'autre à faire pour moi il fallait que
j'y revienne
projet c'était en urgence jeudi rejet
pas j'ai pas chanter j'étais juste au
conseil
c'était quelque chose d'incroyable
j'étais là a pu un remplaçant pour pour
une des chansons
la réaction du public était absolument
incroyable
le lendemain j'ai écrit quatre chansons
veut d'un train d'une traite et je me
suis remis tout de suite est ce que vous
préférez qu'on vous connaissent pour vos
anciens albums ou pour les nouveaux
crois qu'il faut un peu équilibré les
deux mois je suis très fier de notre
passé enfin c'est une situation qui
évolue constamment
aujourd'hui encore le groupe est très
vivant
le solo de guitare de rounds avec steve
on a fait des choses extraordinaires est
super musiciens dans le coup c'est
quelque chose de très stimulant les
toujours une évolution c'est vrai est-ce
que vous pensez que vous avez mieux
vieilli que led zeppelin
prononcé lampe parme
ac et là je vous pensais que ce serait
ridicule de continuer
je crois que quand on n'a aucun la forme
de la physique je crois que c'est le
moment de se retirer
en tout cas d'arrêter de chanter mais la
chanterais pts et du blues parce que là
je pourrai cesse
de quoi vous êtes nostalgique
non-match n'ya pas grand chose dont je
sois nostalgique c'est à dire que
peut-être après un concert on se répéter
dans un autocar
s'écroule à 4 heures du matin et et
jusque là entre la fin du concert je
sais pas où on pense un peu ou pas c'est
pas vraiment de manière nostalgique mais
il ya
des choses marrantes qui sont passés
alors si on n'arrive pas à se dire à
pied on invente des souvenirs on dit
souvent parlant de l'époque sex drugs
and rock'n'roll le rock'n'roll vous
l'avez toujours est ce qu'il vous reste
le sexe et la drogue oui oui
tout ce qui se passe que c'est que notre
groupe n'a jamais donné dans la drogue
on buvait certes du whisky
avec claque ça passe je crois qu'une
fois j'essaie la cocaïne j'ai parlé
trois 3 jours d'affilée dont une comme
ça ça m'a rendu un peu dingue ce truc
j'ai fumé mon premier jour à l'âge de 40
ans
et aux états unis ça ne manque pas donc
la drogue c'était pas tellement d'autres
trucs avec le genre de musique qu'on
faisait je crois qu'il faut rester quand
même assez assez clair et la drogue ou
au contraire 2 ne faisait aucun regret
ça nous a jamais
voilà alors deep purple est en concert à
toulon le 28 octobre donc comme toulon
je connais le rugby vous connaissez le
rugby
j'adore mada
g
[Applaudissements]
j
oui
[Musique]
vous restez avec nous yann c'est l'heure
du blind test et ce soir pour le blind
test nous avons un dj de grande qualité
nous avons monsieur bob 5
l'activité s'est mal
là
observons soir reçoit à l'album de votre
sac car le voilà réalise à peine 3 avec
deux pics d'ozone bravo bonne alors si
le principe du blind test c'est vraiment
simple ben je veux l'interprète voilà
attention didier
ça c'est le hope springs ah ouais ouais
bah oui c'est d'abord ça va commencer
n'a pas commencé mais bien déjà c'est
bien bravo c'est content de ta recrues
elles sont bien là vraiment bien alors
attention dans un premier temps nous
allons jouer par équipes c'est à dire
l'équipe de claude françois junior et
l'équipe de ian gillan et ensuite pour
les banques au vous connaissez le
principe c'est chacun pour sa gueule
c'est la loi de la jungle voilà
attention bob rae je suis pas deux
premiers morceaux
des bayas
m
leïla
maria
passons
[Musique]
hier je voyais à l'arrêt des meilleurs
délais mais je pense qu'un petit ripper
serait de bonne heure
m
j'ignore toc le junior
[Applaudissements]
c'est une équipe de club junior qui se
respecte au moins la mémoire du père
attention donc ça fait un point pour
l'équipe de claude junior zéro point
pour l'équipe de ian gillan attention
bon
[Musique]
à
non
il est resté muet
quand tu regardes
[Musique]
tous
au perchoir
bravo bravo il a fait un poids pour
l'équipe ii ya un poivre l'équipe
tournait toujours derrière rien alors on
s'est tous sourit
taha
et
venus souffler on a
attention comme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
ok très bien tension donc ça fait deux
points pour l'équipe de cloclo un point
pour l'équipe de yann m'vila attention
bob
[Musique]
madonna donc ça fait 2 partout on
continue attention se consomme aussi bon
sens et qu'on s'a tension vous êtes
concentré bien attention bob
internet
eh oui
la compil ma carte c'est énorme c'est 20
attention maintenant tu es très bas vous
êtes tous prêts numéro 6 bob jamel arem
[Musique]
oui sinon
encore que
entre eux
[Musique]
oui
bravo éviter génial aux élus alors
formidable pas produit par le même un
producteur chris jones on s'en tape on
s'en tape et nick et que bien attention
à trouver je veux l'interprète je veux
l'interdire on passe au 7e morceau bob
[Musique]
ja
bigras
adieu
hier tu m'as dit c'est grâce à mon père
pourquoi
il écoute énormément de musique qu'il
écoute de tout et je connais des enfants
qui connaît match quand tu peux regarder
la 3d fin 2004 sérieux dit lui dis merci
merci merci alors intentions sérieuses
avec 4 points alors 7,7
elle est en train de lui ni de vous
planter tous bons on continue bob 5 1
[Musique]
ok
le premier groupe de george michael whan
mais moi quand j'entends bien
quoi
de répéter quand on entend la réponse eh
ben non on n'est pas comme ça attention
je veux l'interprète bones encore
[Musique]
ses proches l'ingénieur méline des
rolling stones bien sûr
à
à sédhiou
[Musique]
attention on arrive aux bongo donc
maintenant y'a plus l'équipe c'est
chacun pour sa gueule ah ouais c'est pas
bien ça c'est pas bien c'est le monde
moderne c'est l'individu s'est pas vu je
sais
mais leurs
missiles en afrique n'a pas cédé à la
tendance pas me chercher la vie et à la
vie est injuste les chaleurs tu sais
bien ouais allons-y donc leader en avion
elle ne cherche pas put en appel sa
peine 20 minutes qu on est peinards tous
les deux là vient pas c'est vrai vous
entendez vachement beau fixe depuis 20
minutes très
attention bob sinclar
[Musique]
ce
soir
[Musique]
et maintenant alors celui qui trouve ça
la gare c'est un des gars mais tu
me gâche tout la cavale des rapetou
t'as jamais
t'es pas un art et histoire c'est pas
sympa il s'est dégradé et je fais chier
à pain alors je suis peinard en plus non
mais vraiment on rejoue personnes sans
abri qui peignait ensemble
dans la même case
quel genre à dire
paris - doubleront concentre toi je t'en
supplie parce que là c'est grave ce
qu'ils trouvent ça est très fort
attention el bahdja globe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au
total aux non
initiés
[Musique]
il a trouvé pilonnant diot comment tu
t'appelles andris bravo fabrice est
énorme
s'ils gagnent le blind test voilà et
maintenant un dernier morceau
[Applaudissements]
et voilà ça c'est dit peur des oiseaux
on va aller
donc c'était tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le jeu vient ce que c'est
aurélien recoing chercheurs le 4 octobre
pistons plombèrent janis et john jay
leach écrite et christophe lambert
thierry lopez paris
françois cluzet jean louis trintignant
sa sortie le 15 octobre tiennent de
france viennent de france la princesse
rebelle c'est valverde g chypre et mario
richard bohringer l'album s'appelle
ségolène
il est
tai chi à paris jusqu'au 18 octobre bon
blague et
soutient la campagne d'amnesty
international or a marché
john est bizarre l'album s'appelle
belles belles belles et sur le maintien
au chaud le single s'appelle j'attendrai
et belles belles belles donc à l'olympia
à partir du 21 novembre
c'est la comédie musicale pierpoljak
l'album s'appelle ce type turbo va la
gagner
dictionnaire amoureux du rugby s'était
invité chez plon mesdames et messieurs
ya une dizaine de titres apple l'album
jabel bananas quiche en concert le 28
octobre à toulon il bob sinclar top 5
albums 3 merci d'avoir
déjà d'or
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 10
km
h
[Musique]
au
programme
et voit ses gains
[Musique]
depuis
les jo b
faux
marçais
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux